demokratie das werden wir nicht
tolerieren meine damen und herren
deutschland bleibt ein raum der freiheit
der sicherheit und des rechts
egal woher ein mensch kommt und welche
sprache er spricht denn unrecht bekämpft
man nicht mit unrecht meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen
die werte der liberalen demokratie sind
die entscheidung der mehrheit
und die freiheit des individuums
der publizist verrät zakaria warnte
schon
2003 also lange bevor der terminus
geläufig wurde vor liberalen demokratien
damit meint er ein staatswesen
dass der mehrheit alles erlaubt und dem
individuum nichts an respekt
entgegenbringt denn eines ist ja auch
wenn alle über alles abstimmen bestimmt
am ende niemand mehr über sich selbst
und deshalb legt die ampel koalition
gerade so viel wert auf beide werte die
demokratie und die freiheit daher
stärken wir den respekt vor dem
individuum denn genau das ist ja gerade
das liberale an der liberalen demokratie
genau deshalb stärken wir die
bürgerrechte durch die ersetzung der
vorratsdatenspeicherung und reformen bei
der quellen-tkü
genau deshalb stärken wir die
selbstbestimmung im familienrecht durch
neue möglichkeiten in einer neuen zeit
und genau deshalb werden wir eine
grundrechts orientierte und
evidenzbasierte sicherheitspolitik
betreiben wir erstellen eine
überwachungs gesamtrechnung mit blick
auf die bestehenden sicherheitsgesetze
und wir unterziehen die
überwachungsbefugnisse des staates einer
generalrevision all das war schon
richtig
all das
richtig als wir den koalitionsvertrag
abgeschlossen haben aber in anbetracht
des verbrecherischen angriffs auf die
prinzipien der liberalen demokratie ist
all das noch wichtiger geworden als es
eh schon war liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
aus dem bundesministerium der justiz
leisten wir unsere beiträge dazu wir tun
die so dass dies hoffentlich auch aus
sicht strenger haushälter bestehen kann
denn im vergleich geben wer nicht
besonders viel geld aus nehmen dafür
aber besonders viel von diesem geld
selber wieder ein
und deshalb meine ich
jeder euro für das haus des rechts und
der freiheit ist eine gute investition
in die liberale demokratie hat wandern
so weit muss justizminister marco
buschmann hat hier die freiheit
besonders betont das hat er auch schon
häufiger gesagt dass er sich als
verteidiger der freiheit in seiner rolle
als
bundesjustizminister versteht sind dass
im moment die wahlen zum
parlamentarischen
kontrollgremium laufen da vor ende der
debatte zum justiz haushalt die beiden
abgeschlossen werden wird natürlich der
minister genauso wie abgeordnete die
jetzt zu diesem geschäftsbereich ja an
der debatte teilnehmen zwischendurch mal
kurze zeit den saal verlassen um von
ihrem wahlrecht entsprechend
gebrauch zu machen
wir beginnen mit der debatte und der
kollege dr günter krings hat für die cdu
csu fraktion das wort
frau präsidentin dass ich zu beginn
meiner rede auf das alternativprogramm
aufmerksam machen dem ich ihn nicht
weiter übel ich kann die situation
verstehen auch bundesminister meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren der
freiheitliche verfassungsstaat hat exakt
zwei mittel um politisch zu agieren um
lebenswirklichkeit zu gestalten geld
also die einnahme von steuern und die
ausgabe dieser gelder andererseits und
zum zweiten gesetzgebung und
rechtsdurchsetzung
regelmäßig habe ich den eindruck dass
wir im umgang mit dem handlungs mittel
geld auch hier im hause viel
skrupelloser sind als im umgang mit dem
recht aber für uns recht würde ich ja da
habe ich das gegenteil jedenfalls
behaupten meine damen und herren aber
weder freiheit noch rechtsstaatlichkeit
sind eben in euro und cent auf zu bieten
und das werden wir in diesen wochen sehr
eindrücklich bei dem tapferen kampf des
ukrainischen volkes gegen die russischen
invasion aber auch bei unserem
sanktionen als antwort auf diesen
angriffskrieg
dieser krieg wird europa verändern er
wird deutschland verändern vieles von
dem was wir bislang
gesagt und gehofft haben hat seine
gültigkeit verloren
der russische präsident führt hier nicht
nur einen krieg gegen die ukraine
sondern auch gegen die demokratie und
dafür zugleich krieg gegen recht und
rechtsstaatlichkeit nicht nur dass wir
hier zeuge des größten völkerrechts
bruchs in der europäischen
nachkriegsgeschichte sein müssen
sondern mit der geplanten besetzung der
ukraine geht es dem kriegsverbrecher im
kreml auch darum keine rechtsstaatlichen
strukturen in seiner nachbarschaft
aufkommen zu lassen
die ukraine setzen ihr leben
für die freiheit und die unter vielen
widrigkeiten ja auf bekannte
rechtsstaatlichkeit in ihrem land und
sie haben auch deshalb unser aller
unterstützung verdient man damit
aus diesem aus diesem grunde habe ich
mich in dieser woche einer petition
angeschlossen die die schaffung eines
weiteren neuen internationalen
sondertribunals für die russischen
kriegsverbrecher fordert nicht als
konkurrenz zu anderen möglichkeiten der
aufarbeitung als ergänzung dazu und den
partnerschaft dazu
und herr bundesminister ich konnte ihnen
sehr viele insbesondere zum thema
ukraine zu stehen was sie gesagt haben
aber ich muss ihnen auch sagen während
die ampel regierung den etat des
generalbundesanwalts in diesen zeiten
doch tatsächlich senken will regel ich
dringend ab wirklich dringend an doch
namens meiner fraktion dass wir im
haushalt des generalbundesanwalts
zusätzliche stellen und mittel
bereitstellen um russische
kriegsverbrechen für künftige verfahren
zu dokumentieren wir sollten dabei auch
ukrainische flüchtlinge ermutigen uns
entsprechende hinweise informationen zu
geben damit wir diesen verbrechen
nachgehen können meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren die
furchtbaren berichtet die uns täglich
aus diesem krieg erreichen relativieren
natürlich manche eben politisch
kontroverse und doch kann die
weltpolitische lage natürlich auch
niemals eine entschuldigung sein für
fehler oder schludrigkeiten auf einer
nationalen politik und auch darüber
müssen wir reden
wir allen ernstes etwa die abschaffung
sie kennen das thema des werbeverbots
für schwangerschafts abbrüche zur ersten
rechtspolitischen priorität erklärt wie
es in der ampel geschehen ist der sollte
so meine wirklich herzliche bitte sein
politisches koordinatensystem doch noch
einmal einer kritischen überprüfung
unterziehen ich erwarte bei einem
solchen thema zumindest viele ist er
gleich zumindest dass die grenzen die
unser grundgesetz und das
verfassungsrecht zum schutz ungeborener
kinder gezogen hat auch ernst genommen
werden und ich erwarte ehrlichkeit
ehrlichkeit in der debatte vielleicht
schon zu viel verlangen ich weiß es
nicht denn derjenige
derjenige der ein werbeverbot streichen
will nimmt da dort doch schon denkt
logisch werbung zumindest zumindest
billigend in kauf billigend in kauf wer
das grundrecht auf leben und die
menschenwürde des embryos im gering
schätzt handelt wie ich finde auch nicht
liberal da geht um grundwerte und
freiheitsrechte und das gegenteil von
liberal sind eben auch die pläne für ein
neues kinder grund richten nur ein
weiteres beispiel zu nennen wir als
union wollen kinder mit und nicht gegen
ihre eltern schützen das war der kern
der von uns mit ausgearbeiteten
vorschlag in der letzten wahlperiode die
ampel will hingegen mehr staatlichen
einfluss bei der kindererziehung zu
lasten der eltern die damit angestrebte
staatliche lufthoheit über den
kinderbetten die kennen wir von olaf
scholz aber bislang nicht von liberale
ja meine damen und herren ich habe
inzwischen den eindruck dass die fdp
hier nicht nur ihre sitzplätze für uns
als unions fraktion frei gemacht hat
sondern gleich noch ihre liberalen
positionen gute stück torte freigeräumt
ich will aber auch
gerne noch auf einen kleinen erfolg des
justizministers und seines ministeriums
eingehen nämlich die gewinnung der
zuständigkeit für den normenkontrollrat
und damit für das wichtige thema der
besseren rechtsetzung
2006 hat eine cdu geführte
bundesregierung die thematik ganz
bewusst im bundeskanzleramt angesiedelt
das hat die bedeutung der aufgabe
unterstrichen aber auch die
durchschlagskraft des normenkontrollrats
ganz erheblich erhöht oder erst wirklich
geschaffen
dass die ampel mehrheit nun eine
zuständigkeit verschiebung in ein
fachressort vornimmt
zeigt dass die koalition insgesamt das
thema nicht mehr so ganz ernst
das ist schlecht für die sache
aber aber baue gerne brücke wenn das
justizministerium diese aufgabe denn
jetzt schon an land gezogen hat das
freut mich ja für den herrn minister
dann machen sie bitte auch was draus ja
und die sorge habe ich ihnen das will
ich doch gerade erklären warum ich die
sorge habe herr kollege der wahlslogan
der fdp im bundestagswahlkampf war ja
glaube ich nie gab es mehr zu tun und er
passt hier wirklich leider wie die faust
aufs auge bei dem thema ja
defizite weiter gesetzgebungs qualität
gab es auch in den letzten jahren
unstreitig aber was wir bei den ersten
arbeitsproben der ampelkoalition erleben
durften erleben mussten ist wirklich ein
neuer tiefpunkt in sachen qualität der
gesetzgebung
und ich denke vielleicht mal ein
beispiel noch ganz frisch aus der
letzten sitzungswoche novellierung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
indem sie dir in auf dem bisherigen
höhepunkt der ansteckungszahlen das gros
der schutzmaßnahmen abgeschafft haben
haben sie den charakter des
infektionsschutz rechts schlichtweg
verkannt es ist eben kein klassisches
gefahrenabwehr recht sondern vor allem
risikovorsorge recht ein solches gesetz
darf also niemals nur die aktuelle
gefahrenlage abdecken sondern es muss
auch noch funktionieren wenn diese sich
verschärft wenn es aber die länder macht
und wehrlos macht ist es eben kein
vorausschauendes sondern ein schlechtes
gesetz wenn man so damit begründet wird
können es ja nur nachbessern ist das
eigentlich denkbar schwächste begründung
und rechtfertigung für ein gesetz meint
habel sei
aber auch der weg zu diesem gesetz
schreibt geschichte in der
geschäftsordnung der bundesregierung ist
aus guten grund vorgeschrieben dass vor
einem kabinettsbeschluss die fachlich
kompetenten verbände zu beteiligen sind
die beteiligung gab es auch die begannen
mittwochs nachts um 1 uhr 8 und endete 8
stunden 52 minuten später sie haben es
wirklich geschafft verbände beteiligen
bei dem zentralen gesetz zu einer bloßen
farce verkommen zu lassen und
wohlgemerkt dieser zeitung ist nicht
durch die dynamik der pandemie
entstanden dann wirst du noch verstehen
sondern weil sich die ressorts an der
stelle ineinander verkeilt haben bei
corona und das haben wir uns auch
gemacht bei der frage impfpflicht das
grundgesetz weist dem bundestag die
entscheidung bei solche wichtigen fragen
zu die regierung legt einen
regierungsentwurf zu und time nicht
großzügig gewissensfragen dem parlament
zu das ist nämlich keine stärkung
sondern eine schwächung des parlaments
was ich ihr unternommen haben meine
damen und herren in zentralen regelungs
bedürftigen fragen vorsichtshalber gar
keinen gesetzentwurf vorzulegen wie hier
ist aber noch kein beitrag für bessere
rechtsetzung vielen dank
günter krings immer dass der
rechtspolitische sprecher der
unionsfraktion und meine damen und
herren sie sehen es schon an diesen
tagen da ist natürlich an vielen orten
der welt etwas worüber wir berichten
wollen demnächst erwarten wir die
pressekonferenz punkt generalsekretär
der nato jetzt die stoltenberg nach dem
gipfeltreffen der nato in brüssel zum
russischen krieg gegen die ukraine
sollte es dort losgehen werden wir das
live senden so lange bleiben wir aber
natürlich hier in der debatte jetzt mit
esther dich ja für die spd-fraktion
im bundeshaushalt sind im zweiten
regierungsentwurf einnahmen und ausgaben
in höhe von jeweils 4 157 milliarden
euro veranschlagt bei steuereinnahmen
höhe von 332 milliarden euro im justiz
haushalt also in diesem 1 207 den wir
jetzt beraten werden gesamtausgaben von
rund 935 millionen euro und einnahmen
von 644 millionen euro hätte nicht
steuereinnahmen sondern eigene einnahmen
eingestellt also beträgt der anteil der
ausgaben des justiz haushaltes am
gesamthaushalt lediglich 0,2 prozent und
es ist ein verwaltungshaushalt das gibt
nicht viel spielraum für projekte
förderprogramme oder zusätzliche neue
ausgabe ein umschichten in einem
vorgang hier fast schier unmöglich
erscheint das justizministerium ist in
erster linie dass gesetzgebung
ministerium entweder durch eigene
gesetze oder durch begleitung der
anderen ministerien in deren
gesetzgebungsprozesse dafür sind
ausgaben von 127 millionen eingestellt
in den letzten zwei jahren kamen aus dem
bundesministerium der justiz
beschleunigt durch die herausforderungen
der bewohner pandemie wichtige gesetze
im sanierungs und insolvenzrecht die
verkürzung der restschuldbefreiung die
mietpreis treiben schutz verwöhne
wohnungskündigung bei mietschulden rund
so weiter ich möchte das jetzt hier in
die ich alles weiter ausführen im
haushalt des bundesministeriums der
justiz entfällt in dieser legislatur das
kapitel der verbraucherpolitik was ich
persönlich sehr bedauerlich dass betrug
betreut hat auch im rechtsausschuss und
wir das mal sehr viel spaß gemacht hat
zum zuständigkeit des bundesministeriums
der justiz gehören drei von fünf
bundesgerichten nämlich der
bundesgerichtshof das
bundesverwaltungsgericht und der
bundesfinanzhof sowie der
generalbundesanwalt und dafür sind
aufgaben vorgesehen von insgesamt 162
millionen euro
auch der zentrale dienstleister der
deutschen justiz nämlich das bundesamt
für justiz wird mit haushaltsmitteln im
einzelplan und sieben veranschlagt und
zwar mit ausgaben in höhe von 990
millionen hier möchte ich aber einmal
die einnahmenseite näher beleuchten
jeder der bereits einmal ein
führungszeugnis beantragt hat hat dazu
beigetragen dass dem justiz haushalt
dadurch auch einnahmen zufließen
1200 beschäftigte bieten im bundesamt
unter anderem bürgerdienst zb neben dem
führungszeugnis auch hilfe bei
auslandsadoptionen auslands unterhalt
internationalen sorgerecht sie führen
die register bei der muster
feststellungsklage das
gewerbezentralregister und sind
schlichtungsstelle für den luft wenn man
auf der seite nachdruck der wird
überrascht sein was das bundesamt für
justiz alles leistet
sie bieten dienstleister für gerichte
und behörden zum beispiel justiz
fortbildung internationale rechtshilfe
in strafsachen sowie im zivil- und
handelssachen
und sie sind zuständig für die
vollstreckung bei eu geldstrafen und
geldbußen sowie auch bei eu cand
kontopfändungen und insgesamt sind dafür
im haushalt einnahmen in höhe von 135
millionen die also über den ausgaben
liegen veranschlagt ein weitaus größerer
betrag wird an einnahmen für gewerbliche
schutzrechte im rahmen von gebühren in
höhe von 455 millionen beim deutschen
patent und markenamt geschätzt bei
ausgaben von
245 millionen euro auch da liegen die
einnahmen über den ausgaben und liebe
kolleginnen kollegen das ist ein
ausdruck dafür dass deutschland ein
forschungs und innovationsstandort ist
und das findet sich in justiz haushalt
wieder dieser indikator ich finde das
großartig
selbst in der krise oder vielleicht
gerade die krise hat die anmeldung von
patenten im bereich von
umweltfreundlichen antriebstechniken im
bereich von digitalisierung
medizintechnik infektionsschutz und
anderen bereichen beflügelt darauf
können wir alle stolz sein liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
sie sehen es ist eine besonderheit
dieses zwar kleinen aber trotzdem sehr
bedeutsamen haushalts des
bundesministeriums der justiz
es besteht nämlich eine mehr als 68
prozentigen deckungsquote
die bundesrepublik ist ein moderner
verfassungsstaat der drei wesentliche
aufgaben hat zum ersten die auf
sicherheit also die landesverteidigung
zum zweiten die innere sicherheit also
der frieden in der gesellschaft und zum
dritten die gesellschaftsgestaltung
darunter verstehen wir all das was wir
mit sozialer sicherung und
daseinsvorsorge in verbindung bringen
ich meine grundvoraussetzung ist dabei
zunächst die innere sicherheit die
bürgerinnen und bürger erwarten von uns
nicht dass alles perfekt funktioniert
dass jede ungerechtigkeit aufgelöst
jedes verbrechen verhindert und jeder
oder jede grenzenlos freiheit genießen
kann zumindest die mehrheit erwartet
dass nicht in diesem haus und diese
grundsätze sind verfassungsmäßig
verankerte
artikel 20 grundgesetz begründet für die
bundesrepublik unter anderem das
sozialstaatsprinzip das
demokratieprinzip und das
rechtsstaatsprinzip sie werden sich
fragen warum ist mir diese klarstellung
in dieser haushaltsdebatte so wichtig
mir ist das wichtig weil das
bundesministerium der justiz ein
gesetzgebungs ministerium ist das an die
verfassungsmäßige ordnung gebunden ist
weil bei uns die vollziehende gewalt und
die rechtsprechung an gesetz und recht
gebunden sind und ich finde unser
rechtsstaat funktioniert liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich finde es beschämend dass
ein demokratisch gewählter abgeordneter
hier von der rechten seite in
russland in medien behaupten darf es
gebe in deutschland keine demokratie und
andere meinungen würden durch regierende
elite in deutschen medien im internet
und sogar durch körperliche gewalt
unterdrückt und es bestürzt mich
zutiefst dass durch solche äußerungen
dem kriegstreiber putin von deutschen
abgeordneten schützenhilfe geleistet
wird
es ist fast unerträglich aber es macht
mich nicht stumpf denn die freiheit von
abgeordneten die hass und hetze gegen
deutschland verbreiten endet genau
hier wo meine freiheit beginnt freiheit
ist nämlich hier auf erden nicht
grenzenlos hier ist die grenze und ich
bin dankbar dass wir in deutschland
freiheitsrechte haben die durch unsere
verfassung garantiert werden
handlungsfreiheit in artikel 2
meinungsfreiheit in artikel 5
versammlungsfreiheit in artikel 8 die
die rechte anderer nicht verletzen
dürfen und nur beschränkt werden können
durch ein gesetz sie verbrannten sie
bestätigen das ja gerade dass sie das
sogar auch noch gut finden was war
passiert
in russland zu behaupten in deutschland
gebe es keine demokratie und keine
meinungsfreiheit ist ein vernichtender
schlag ins gesicht aller menschen in
russland die gegen diesen krieg auf die
straße gehen die sich öffentlichen
rundfunk und fernsehen gegen diesen
krieg und frieden aussprechen die mutig
widerstand leisten und damit um
sie befürchten müssen ich bin entsetzt
wie weit sie hier im rechten rand gehen
um sich verbündete zu suchen und die
äußerungen ihres kollegen dokumentiert
bis auf einen kurzen kommentar des
stellvertretenden bundessprecher ist er
ja hier auch schon wieder von der
rechten seite das zwischenruf stehen
lassen
mir fällt es schwer ihre redebeiträge zu
ertragen und trotzdem nehmen die
demokratischen parteien in diesem haut
diese herausforderung an aber
meinungsfreiheit bedeutet nicht dass wir
ihre hetzerischen kommentare
widerspruchslos hinnehmen müssen nein
genau hier ist der ort um sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen
aber nicht von ihnen herr brandner in
der öffentlichen debatte
im ständerat hält das aus und ich bin
überzeugt die mehrheit der
demokratischen parteien hier im haus die
sich zu unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung bekennt und
diese nicht verleugnet sieht das genauso
wie ich verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen
unser rechtsstaat funktioniert und das
verdanken wir unseren gesetzgebungs
ministerium dessen haushalt wir hier
debattieren sowie vielen engagierten
beschäftigten in justiz und den
gerichten die in der panama an ihre
grenzen gekommen sind ich freue mich auf
spannende haushaltsberatungen ich habe
mich vom ministerium schon so einiges
gehört was man vielleicht auch noch mal
anpacken könnte dafür werden zusätzliche
ausgaben erforderlich mal gucken ob wir
da noch was verändern können vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
es war das für die sozialdemokraten ist
hier in ihre rede sehr lange auf eine
äußerung eingegangen auf ein interview
des fdp-bundestagsabgeordneten
sein verfügung gilt das heißt die maske
kann hier form von der amtierenden
präsidentin abgenommen werden wenn sie
die rednerinnen und redner aufruft oder
hinweise zur debatte gibt und natürlich
von der aktuellen rednerinnen oder dem
aktuellen redner am pult für
zwischenrufe haben wir schon seit wochen
die praxis dass die maske mund und nase
weiter bedeckt das wort also hier noch
eine äußerung von
bundestagsvizepräsidentin petra pau und
nun kann die afg auf die vorherige rede
antworten michael espendiller spricht
jetzt für seine fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen liebe zuschauer im saal
und bei youtube freiheit demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit diesen dreiklang
haben wir diese woche hier in diesem
haus schon häufig gehört
gebetsmühlenartig wiederholt doch wie
genau steht es eigentlich damit die
freiheit des menschen liegt nicht darin
dass er tun kann was er will sondern
dass er nicht tun muss was er nicht will
das sagte dressel
nun bedeutet das dass man keine steuern
mehr zahlen muss oder kirchen nicht mehr
bezahlen muss je natürlich nicht bei
dann beginnt sich die geister ja
durchaus schon zu scheiden ja bei der
höhe der steuern oder die höhe der
bußgelder beides übrigens kritisiert von
der fdp während ihrer oppositionszeit
weiß dass hier noch jemand diese
flammende plädoyers gegen die
finanzielle ausbeutung der bürger und
den kampf für die freiheit der kampf
gegen übergriffige corona maßnahmen für
mehr wissenschaftlichkeit bei der
politischen entscheidungsfindung gegen
einen bevormundenden staat und für mehr
eigenverantwortung und natürlich der
kampf gegen die impfpflicht unsere
gesellschaft hat noch nie so tiefe
einschnitte in ihr gewohntes leben
hinnehmen müssen mit den letzten zwei
jahren der korona politik und während
ganz zu beginn doch alle auf die
maßnahmen vertraut haben wurde den
meisten menschen relativ schnell klar
dass man sich nicht ewig vor einem virus
verstecken kann die politik der
koalition von union und spd griff das
auf und versprach den menschen die
rückkehr zu normalität sobald es denn
eine impfung gebe eine impfung die ferne
verfügbar sein sollte aber wo natürlich
niemand gezwungen werden sollte sie zu
nehmen bis hierhin war noch alles
halbwegs normal aber ab einem gewissen
punkt wurde die pandemie nicht mehr
überwiegend rational bekämpft sondern
sie wurde zu einem spielball der
üblichen politischen spielchen die die
konsens parteien die untereinander
spielen und die übrigens mit der sache
nichts mehr zu tun haben und auch nicht
mehr mit dem wohle des volkes es stand
verschiedene wahl an und jede partei
hatte gegen die jeweils andere partei
ein und dieselbe politische granate in
der hand und da stand sinngemäß drauf
die maßnahmen sind nicht ausreichend
wegen ihrer partei der menschen und was
folgte war ein überbietungswettlauf
anforderungen der besseren härteren
endgültige rinnen und mehr und mehr und
mehr maßnahmen via cfd haben diesen
irrsinn sehr früh erkannt kritisiert und
uns für eine schrittweise rücknahme der
maßnahmen eingesetzt
die eben erwähnte granate flucht
natürlich auch in unsere richtung aber
zum glück lautet unser partei motto ja
mut zur wahrheit aber auch der fdp
erkannte irgendwann dass ein relevanter
wähleranteil da ist der sich ein ende
dieser ganzen maßnahmen wünschte und
mehr noch man durfte die unzufriedenen
ja nicht zur ard wechseln lassen also
begann auch die fdp den maßnahmen
irrsinn zu kritisieren und sie bekamen
auch dankbaren zuspruch das wurde später
sogar noch verstärkt und zwar als die
bürger nach sehr viel geduld sich
endlich an die deutsche gerichtsbarkeit
ändert haben und klagten doch die
gerichte auf die unsere bürger in ihrem
glauben an rechtsstaatlichkeit alles
gesetzt hatten fanden das alles so in
ordnung mit den maßnahmen ich kann mich
noch gut daran erinnern als ich damals
noch mit zu juristen gesprochen habe wie
schockiert die wahl und die bürger die
schon so viel haben auf sich nehmen
müssen fühlten sich auf einen schlag
machtlos und im stich gelassen aber es
gab hoffnung auf erlösung denn die herrn
kubicki lindner buschmann kämpften für
die freiheit und versprachen keine
impfpflicht einzuführen ich muss
gestehen ich habe ihn damals auch
durchaus geglaubt und ich habe mich auch
sehr darüber freut dass nicht nur die
afd zu einem realen politik kurs
zurückgekommen ist und genau deshalb
kann ich sehr gut
nachvollziehen wie verraten verkauft und
verarscht sich ihre wähler jetzt fühlen
sie unterstützen jetzt alles wogegen sie
gekämpft haben und ein
fdp-justizminister der nicht klar und
deutlich sagt dass die geplante
impfpflicht ein absolutes no go ist
nicht die rechtsstaatliche rote fahne
hebt und einen lauterbach nicht
entschieden widerspricht der ist ein
schlag ins gesicht für alle freunde der
freiheit
die frage die frage nach der
kompromisslose verteidigung des rechts
auf körperliche selbstbestimmung wäre
für mich für meine fraktion ein
absolutes deal oder no deal aber die fdp
wirft einer koalition zur mehrheit die
genau das abschaffen möchte und niemand
der ein herz in der brust und ein
minimum an erinnerungsvermögen hat wird
ihnen das jemals verzeihen vielen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit
michael espendiller war das setzt im
haushaltsausschuss wie auch der nächste
redner das ist bruno höhne für bündnis
90 die grünen hier in der debatte zum
einzelplan 07 des
bundesjustizministeriums die grünen hat
nun der kollege bruno himmel das wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lieber herr
buschmann hersteller von einer partei
die vom verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem verdachtsfall eingeordnet
ist lassen wir uns nix über die
verfassungsmäßigkeit unserer
gesetzgebung seien nur da die das habe
ich mit herrn sie vor ihrer eigenen
haustür
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir beraten den einzelplan 7 den etat
des justizministeriums und im zentrum
dieser debatte stehen damit unweigerlich
unser rechtsstaat und unsere demokratie
der funktionierende rechtsstaat ist eine
wesentliche säule unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung ja die
unabhängige gerichtsbarkeit ist das
fundament unserer freien und offenen
gesellschaft
der wert von freiheit und demokratie
ist unermesslich und er wird uns in
diesen tagen durch den
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
putins brutal vor augen geführt und man
kann es nicht oft genug sagen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
bundesregierung wir als parlamentarier
in wir stehen gemeinsam und
unverrückbarer gemeinsam mit unseren
europäischen partnern an der seite der
ukraine und dafür bin ich in allen sehr
dankbar
der etat des bj
mit 597 millionen euro für
personalausgaben im großen maß von
kontinuität und stabilität geprägt so
wie eben auch unser rechtsstaat und wenn
sie mir eine bemerkung erlauben lieber
herr buschmann dass sie als eines ihrer
ersten vorhaben in ihrer ja noch recht
kurzen amtszeit gemeinsam mit ministerin
eine spiegel die streichung des 219 aus
dem strafgesetzbuch vorangetrieben haben
das rechne ich ihm hoch an herr
buschmann endlich kommen wir in der
gesellschaftlichen realität des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts an
endlich machen wir schluss mit diesen
unrecht 219 hält es höchste zeit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
sie sehen wir haben uns als koalition
einiges vorgenommen der einzug der
digitalisierung in die justiz wird in
den kommenden jahren von dieser
regierung vorangebracht wir legen dafür
den digital pakt für die justiz auf und
klar bei dabei ist und das will ich
unmissverständlich auch als mitglied der
partei bündnis 90 die grünen klar machen
wir werden dabei ein besonderes
augenmerk auf die konsequente wahrung
der bürger/innen rechte und des
datenschutz legen
sehr geehrte damen und herren lassen sie
mich diese gelegenheit nutzen und an
dieser stelle den gemeinnützigen
stiftungen und vereinen danken die ja
aus diesem etat gefördert werden und die
eine extrem wichtige arbeit leisten in
unserem gemeinsamen kampf gegen
diskriminierung gegen rassismus und
gegen antisemitismus
die entsprechenden ansätze im entwurf
werden auch hohem niveau verstetigt in
teilen erhöht beispielsweise bei der
stiftung forum recht um eine million
euro oder auch bei der internationalen
stiftung für rechtliche zusammenarbeit
und 460.000 euro wir stärken die arbeit
für vielfalt gerechtigkeit und
demokratie das ist das richtige signal
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und mit blick auf die justizbehörden ist
festzuhalten dass der pakt für den
rechtsstaat wirkung entfaltet hat auch
wenn wir in einigen feldern sicherlich
noch nachholbedarf haben herausgreifen
möchte ich hier exemplarisch die
hasskriminalität wo wir nach wie vor das
muss man sagen ein vollzugsdefizit haben
und und ländern müssen gemeinsam noch
besser darin werden diese straftaten
frühzeitig zu erkennen dieser anschläge
auf unser grundgesetz konsequent zu
verfolgen und zu ahnden da sind wir
gemeinsam in der verantwortung
egal ob in der analogen welt oder im
digitalen raum das internet ist eben
kein rechts freies paralleluniversum
hass ist keine meinung und das werden
wir auch ihren rechten trollen ganz ganz
deutlich machen darauf können sie sich
verlassen
und was passiert wenn wir die bedeutung
des rechtsstaatlichkeit prinzips wie es
sich aus unserem grundgesetz artikel 20
ergibt wenn wir diese bedeutung nicht
unentwegt hochhalten ja wenn wir unsere
lebendige demokratie nicht mit allen
mitteln verteidigen was dann passiert
das können wir in der in russland sehen
wo kritische stimmen weggesperrt und
mundtot gemacht werden wo die justiz
längst nicht mehr unabhängig ist wo ein
klima der angst vor behörden herrscht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen im
inneren wie im äußeren wir stellen uns
derartigen tendenzen mit aller kraft
entgegen wir stehen für eine bürgernahe
für eine transparente justiz auf
augenhöhe wir schützen den rechtsstaat
und wir verteidigen unsere lebendige
demokratie wehrhaft ist gegen die feinde
der freiheit auch die die da ganz rechts
sitzen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
ohnehin war das bündnis 90/die grünen im
bundestag wir warten weiterhin auf die
pressekonferenz des generalsekretärs der
nato wie jens stoltenberg nach dem
gipfeltreffen der nato und brüssel
mittlerweile hat sich diese
pressekonferenz verschoben ist jetzt für
viertel vor zwei angekündigt wir halten
sie natürlich auf dem laufenden und hier
im plenum im bundestag spricht nun
klarer bünger rechtspolitische
sprecherin der linksfraktion
sehr geehrte präsidentin sehr geehrter
herr bundesminister liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die bundesregierung hat in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag
angekündigt dass sie das strafrecht auf
den prüfstand stellen würde das begrüßen
wir
ankündigungen reichen aber nicht aus sie
müssen die vorhaben auch umsetzen herr
buschmann sie haben es selbst in einem
interview gesagt weniger menschen sollen
wegen sogenannter ersatzfreiheitsstrafen
in haft kommen denn wer zu einer
geldstrafe verurteilt wird und diese
nicht bezahlen kann muss stattdessen ins
gefängnis andere länder der eu sind hier
viel weiter und auch in deutschland muss
endlich etwas passieren
streichen sie die ersatzfreiheitsstrafen
zumindest für diejenigen die die die gar
kein geld haben die
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe ist mittlerweile
zur häufigsten form der freiheitsstrafe
geworden darauf weist auch der jurist
bohnen steinke
2009 10 saßen schätzungsweise 51 tausend
personen hinter gittern allein aus dem
grund weil sie eine geldstrafe nicht
zahlen konnten damit werden arme
menschen doppelt bestraft von
ersatzfreiheitsstrafen sind besonders
häufig menschen betroffen die ohne
ticket im öffentlichen verkehr fahren
nach § 265 a des strafgesetzbuches wird
mit freiheitsstrafe bis zu einem jahr
oder mit geldstrafe bestraft wer sich
die beförderung durch ein verkehrsmittel
erschleicht zum vergleich wer
beispielsweise ohne parkschein parkt
muss ein bußgeld bezahlen begeht aber
keine straftat alles andere wäre auch
vollkommen unverhältnismäßig das ist
beim fahren ohne fahrschein aber auch
sucht deshalb wollen wir diese
ungleichbehandlung ab
2020 gab es über
43.000 verurteilung wegen fahrens ohne
fahrschein meistens geht es dabei um
geldstrafen trotzdem müssen schätzungen
zufolge jedes jahr mehrere tausend
menschen in den knast weil sie ohne
ticket gefahren sind und wählen betrifft
das nicht diejenigen die einfach
vergessen haben sich ein ticket zu
kaufen sondern arme und prekär lebende
menschen obdachlose und suchtkranke die
sich kein ticket leisten können und erst
recht keine geldstrafe bezahlen können
und ich will ihnen sagen der damalige
spd politiker karl liebknecht hat den
begriff klassenjustiz geprägt natürlich
hat sich seitdem viel gewandelt aber
eines hat sich nicht geändert vor dem
gesetz sind nicht alle gleich das ist
ungerecht und das muss sich aus unserer
sicht ändern
[Applaus]
angeblich oder vermeintlichen schwarz
fahrerin kommt es regelmäßig zu
gewaltexzessen ich nenne mal ein
beispiel im märz 20 21 wird ein mann von
einem polizeihund der bund der
bundespolizei gejagt und wird von
beamten überwältigt gefesselt und zur
polizeiwache gebracht was hat dieser
mann getan er war nicht gewalttätig
gegenüber anderen menschen nein er ist
ohne ticket im regionalexpress gefahren
das ist kein einzelfall immer wieder
kommt es hier zu übergriffen dieser
umgang mit menschen weil sie sich kein
ticket leisten können ist absolut
unverhältnismäßig deshalb werden wir zur
streichung des § 265 a 1 ein
gesetzentwurf einbringen
und 2018 haben wir das gemeinsam mit den
grünen gefordert ich weiß dass es für
einige von ihnen wie der kollegin canan
bayram ein wichtiges thema ist ich bitte
sie dass sie uns an dieser stelle
unterstützen
denn die initiative freiheitsgrad hier
im übrigen schon großartiges geleistet
die aktivisten sind nämlich der meinung
dass man sich nicht auf die politik
verlassen kann das ist ja auch in
gewisser weise verständlich die
initiative befreiten nämlich
deutschlandweit menschen aus dem
gefängnis wegen fahrens ohne fahrschein
die hinter gittern sind deshalb sie
haben bisher 305 personen freigekauft
424 1051 hafttage aufgelöst und dem
staat damit 3,6 millionen euro erspart
die die inhaftierung der menschen noch
gekostet hätte vielen dank an euch an
dieser stelle
ersatz her
nicht nur ungerecht nein sie sind auch
noch teuer für die steuerzahlerin wenn
wir den 265 anstreichen dann sorgen wir
nicht nur für eine enorme entlastung bei
den gerichten sondern auch in den
justizanstalten außerdem würde man einen
paragraphen den die nazis 1935 aus der
sozialdarwinistischen gründen eingeführt
haben aus dem stgb entfernen dafür ist
wirklich höchste zeit
um die ungleichbehandlung im recht zu
verringern braucht es natürlich mehr als
dass das ist klar es braucht auch eine
gut ausgestattete justiz und der
personal-etat im haushaltsplan sollte
daher noch viel deutlicher aufgestockt
werden und es sollte in jedem
strafverfahren auch pflichtverteidigerin
für alle geben vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat dr thorsten liebt für die
fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundesminister buschmann
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen lieber
herr kollege doktor krings ich danke
ganz herzlich für die vorlesung die sie
uns vorhin haben angedeihen lassen aber
ich kann ihnen versichern sie brauchen
sich keine sorgen zu machen um den
liberalen kompass der fdp in dieser
bundesregierung während wir
während wir zur beseitigung von
rechtsunsicherheit zum beispiel den 219
a stgb abschaffen ist es doch ihre
fraktion sind es ihre parteien die bei
jedem publikumsträchtigen öffentlichen
ereignis nach neuen strafvorschriften
oder nach verstößen von
strafvorschriften sorgen und das ist
keine liberale
justizpolitik liberale justizpolitik ist
das was wir machen
es ist mir ganz persönlich eine ehre das
bundesministerium in diesem hause nicht
nur in der rolle als stellvertretender
vorsitz des rechtsausschusses sondern
eben auch haushalterisch begleiten zu
dürfen drei themen möchte ich heute
ansprechen
erst der rechtsstaat ist die schon
angesprochen einer der wesentlichen
grundpfeiler unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung und über den
etat dieses grundpfeiler sprechen wir
heute das ist wichtig zu betonen denn
das vertrauen in justiz und rechtsstaat
ist gerade in herausfordernden zeiten in
zeiten der krise besonders notwendig
demokratie und rechtsstaat sind nämlich
keine schönwetter ereignisse und
schönwetter institutionen sie beweisen
gerade in der krise ihren wert und
gerade in der krise sind wir gemeinsam
als demokratinnen und demokraten
gefordert diese werte des rechtsstaats
zu verteidigen
heute vor genau einem monat am 24
februar
2022 sind wir zeugen zeugen geworden des
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
russlands auf die ukraine ein besonders
perfider und massiver eingriff in
demokratie freiheit und
rechtsstaatlichkeit
man mag die frage aufwerfen was hat das
mit dem rechtsstaat hier zu tun ich sage
sehr sehr viel denn im rechtsstaat da
schließe ich mich den bundesminister
gerne an gehört auch diese rechtliche
aufarbeitung eines völkerrechtlichen
angriffskrieges maßgeblich dazu und wir
können stolz darauf sein mit der
generalbundesanwaltschaft und diesem
land eine institution zu haben die
besonders aktiv und besonders kompetent
in der lage ist derartige sachverhalte
aufzuklären und aus zu ermitteln darauf
setzen wir auch alle gemeinsam für die
aufarbeitung dieses krieges in der
ukraine freundinnen freunde
und wir werden selbstverständlich in den
haushaltsberatungen auch sehr genau
darauf gucken ob wir das auch mit dem
was angesetzt ist ermöglichen denn um es
klar zu sagen auch im krieg auch im
konflikt sind es wir als freiheitliche
demokratie die den rechtsstaatlichen
kompass nicht verlieren und auch das
unterscheidet eine demokratie von einer
diktatur
zum zweiten punkt
digitalisierung von justiz und
rechtsstaat bietet war große chancen und
zwar insbesondere auch für den zugang
der bürgerinnen und bürger zum recht zum
rechtsschutz und dazu haben wir uns als
koalition besonders ambitionierte
vorhaben aus ausgedacht die verstetigung
des paktes für den rechtsstaat gehört
dazu ergänzt durch einen digital takt
aber eben auch vereinfachte verfahren
für klein forderungen bei niemandem soll
der zugang zum recht daran scheitern
dass die forderung zu klein oder das
geld zu denen ich es liebe freundinnen
und
dennoch ist wichtig als sparsamer
haushälter auch an einer stelle zu
betonen pakt für den rechtsstaat
bedeutet wenn wir aus bundesmitteln dort
gemeinsam mit den ländern zu lösungen
kommen dass der gemeinsam mit den
ländern dazu kommen müssen welche die
richtigen wege und die richtigen
entscheidungen gibt es geht nicht darum
ein füllhorn auszuschütten sondern
gemeinsam als bund und länder dafür
sorgen dass wir gezielt die
digitalisierung zu dem erfolg bringen in
der justiz den wir alle gemeinsam
möchten
eines möchte ich besonders besonders
hinweisen an der stelle 20 jahre anwalts
erfahrung zeigen mir dass es besonders
in diesen bereichen notwendig ist dass
wir alle beteiligten an den tisch
bekommen dazu gehören die anwälte dazu
da gehören aber auch berufe wie die
rechtspflegerin und rechtspfleger auch
das gerichtsvollzieher wesen dazu ich
halte es für notwendig dass wir bei
allen verhandlungen und detailplanung
mit allen gemeinsam dafür sorgen den
sprung in das digitalisierungs zeitalter
gemeinsam zudem zu führen was wir wollen
es sichert die funktionsfähigkeit des
rechtsstaates dass es unser aller
gemeinsame aufgabe und diese ampel wird
an dieser stelle liefern und den
modernsten digitalen und funktions
texten rechtsstaat in europa zu
gewährleisten vielen dank
[Applaus]
sehen auch und weiterhin und schauen wir
mit einem auge nach brüssel da treffen
sich übrigens auch die regierung starten
der regierungschefs der g 7 staaten auch
im nato hauptquartier beraten sie auch
zur gleichen zeit sie die nato waren sie
dort auch eben
auto wegfahren gesehen
volker ullrich spricht jetzt im
deutschen bundestag sprecher für rechte
csu landesgruppe
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren der etat des
bundesjustizministeriums hat das
geringste volumen aller
einzelpläne und es würde nur gut zwei
tage reichen um den sozialetat
abzudecken er ist dennoch von
elementarer bedeutung
weil wir wissen dass rechtsstaatlichkeit
demokratie begründet und weil dieser
etat auch mit dem deutschen patent und
markenamt grundlegend den schutz des
geistigen eigentums begründet und das
deutsche patent und markenamt und diese
hinweis sei mir gestattet
hat einnahmen von 450 millionen euro
rund und dem stehen gegenüber 255
millionen euro ausgaben
das zeigt wie gut dieses amt arbeitet
aber es deutet auch darauf hin dass
möglicherweise gerade für startups und
unternehmer gründer bei der frage der
gebühren für geistiges eigentum formaten
anmeldungen noch raum für senkungen
besteht um damit die
unternehmensgründung auch im bereich des
geistigen eigentums zu verbessern
wir müssen in diesem haushalt auch über
den generalbundesanwalt sprechen und
zwar ganz konkret wegen des krieges in
der ukraine
hier finden
kriegsverbrechen statt diese müssen
dokumentiert werden aber entscheidend
ist auch dass wohl im hintergrund des
weltrechtsprinzip
es nirgendwo auf der welt eine zuflucht
für kriegsverbrecher geben darf und
rechtspolitisch muss ganz klar sein
kriegsverbrechen gehören aufgeklärt
angeklagt und abgeurteilt und dazu
braucht die justiz die kapazitäten und
wenn der generalbundesanwalt für
dokumentation und struktur
ermittlungsverfahren mehr stellen
braucht muss er sie jetzt bekommen wir
sprechen auch über die frage bis
funktionieren des rechtsstaats und
da möchte ich klar und deutlich zum
ausdruck bringen der rechtsstaat in
deutschland funktioniert er arbeitet
korrekt wer immer den eindruck erwecken
möchte der rechtsstaat würde nicht
ordnungsgemäß funktionieren stellt sich
auf die seite derjenigen die aus anderen
motiven den rechtsstaat in misskredit zu
bringen möchten das sind feinde der
freiheit wir stehen zum recht dass in
deutschland verwirklicht wird
aber natürlich muss dieser rechtsstaat
besser werden das bedeutet er muss
digitaler werden
ich finde es gut und richtig dass der
digital packt der justiz weiter
fortgeführt wird und dass die frage wie
können wir verfahren nicht nur im
strafrechts bereich sind auch im
zivilrecht bereich digitale gestalten
eine zentrale rolle erhält
wir müssen auch dafür sorge tragen dass
im strafverfahren
ein paradigmenwechsel dergestalt
eintreten kann das vielleicht auch die
hauptverhandlungen
wort für wort protokolliert werden ob
wir deswegen
eine audio video so eine aufzeichnung
brauchen das mag ich infrage stellen
aber ich glaube dass durch
digitalisierung hier mehr raum entsteht
um strafverfahren auch aufzuzeichnen und
damit auch die frage von rechtsmitteln
praktikabler zu gestalten aber wenn über
den digitalen bereich sprechen dann
dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass in der
digitalen sphäre auch grausame
straftaten entstehen und dort auch ihren
raum haben ich denke einen drogenhandel
im park nett ich denke auch und die
furchtbaren verbrechen des
kindesmissbrauchs und der kinderplanung
kraft und in diesem zusammenhang braucht
der rechtsstaat auch die entscheidenden
aufklärungs instrumentarien und ich weiß
dass man über einzelheiten der
vorratsdatenspeicherung trefflich
verfassungsrechtlich streiten kann aber
die vorratsdatenspeicherung in abrede zu
stellen wäre vor dem hintergrund des
aufklärungs bedürfnis des staates mehr
als fahrlässig wir halten daran fest
möchte auch bei dem thema des
rechtspolitischen dialogs zwischen bund
und ländern noch kurs auf das thema
impfpflicht zu sprechen es gibt einen
gesetzentwurf
den der bundeskanzler der vizekanzler
nach der bundesgesundheitsminister in
ihrer funktion als abgezeichnet haben
es geht es nicht um die
gesundheitspolitische bewertung dieses
gesetzentwurfes aber
was mir bei diesem entwurf fehlt und
diese frage muss diskutiert werden ist
nämlich der umstand was macht das denn
eigentlich mit unserer justiz auf der
ebene der amtsgerichte wenn wir eine
situation gegenüber stehen bei dem
möglicherweise hunderttausende von neuen
bußgeldverfahren haben im rahmen der
impfpflicht dass in diesem gesetzentwurf
zum thema justiz praktisch nichts steht
zeigt dass hier ein großer nachholbedarf
besteht meine damen und herren ich
kann nur darauf hinweisen
dass bei der schwerpunktsetzung ist
darum gehen muss die aktuellen
herausforderungen des rechts abzubilden
dass neben der frage digitalisierung
auch das soziale mietrecht es geht darum
dass im bereich des mietrechts zu regeln
was den menschen auf den nägeln brennt
die frage der kündigungen beispielsweise
oder der weiter ansteigenden mietpreis
ich glaube dass eine fokussierung dass
eine fokussierung auf themen die er dem
koalitionsfrieden dienen wie § 19a nicht
im mittelpunkt der rechtspolitischen
agenda stehen sollte
es geht
abschließend darum dass wir das recht
verteidigen und deutlich machen dass
freiheit demokratie recht voraussetzt
und dass wir rechtlich diskreditieren
sondern es in den etatplänen abbilden
aber lassen wir uns gemeinsam über diese
notwendigen verbesserungen sprechen
herzlichen dank
so fordert es volker ullrich sprecher
von rechteck
csu-landesgruppe hier in der debatte zum
etat des bundes justizministers im marco
buschmann
935 millionen euro sind in das seminar
fit us ministerien vorgesehen
sonja ich wähle spricht jetzt sprechen
für echte spd-fraktion
werte frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen
und kollegen der demokratischen
fraktionen der haushalt des
bundesministeriums der justiz ist im
vergleich zu anderen einzelplänen recht
klein in seiner leistung und reichweite
aber bei weitem nicht zu unterschätzen
gerade in der heutigen zeit einen monat
nach dem völkerrechtswidrigen überfall
und angriffskriegs putins auf die
ukraine und einer zeit in der wir
weltweit die zunahme von autoritären
regime haben ist es wichtig einen gut
funktionierenden rechtsstaat nach innen
und nach außen zu haben
aus diesem grund begrüßen wir
ausdrücklich die entscheidung des
internationalen
gerichtshofes den angriffskrieg als
völkerrechtswidrig darzustellen und food
ihnen auch zu fordern die
kriegshandlungen sofort einzustellen der
minister wies darauf hin nach innen es
ist sehr sehr wichtig dass der
generalbundesanwalt
entsprechende ermittlungen die schon
angesprochen wurden aufgenommen hat in
der ampelkoalition arbeiten wir
gemeinsam an der fortentwicklung der
modernisierung und der stärkung unseres
rechtsstaats denn es gilt die stärkung
des recht und nicht das recht des
stärkeren
hierfür sind gerade die
haushaltsentscheidungen und
verhandlungen natürlich entscheiden denn
insbesondere auch die ausstattung der
obersten bundesgerichte und des
generalbundesanwalts haben hier einen
unermesslichen stellenwert hinter dem
vermeintlichen standardtitel
finanzierung der bundesgerichte verbirgt
sich folglich das rückgrat unseres
rechtsstaats
besonders herauszustellen ist dabei dass
gerade während der kroner pandemie an
unseren gerichten und es nicht nur auf
bundesebene die wir hier heute
besprechen fortwährend ein erhöhtes maß
an arbeit unter besonders schwierigen
bedingungen geleistet wurde denn die
arbeit konnte nicht verkürzt werden sie
musste fortwährend weiter geführt werden
hierfür gebührt allen kolleginnen und
kollegen in der justiz unser aufrechter
dank
denn mit jedem blick in jede akte machen
sie unseren rechtsstaat lebendig hier
ist jeder einzelne cent sehr sehr gut
investiertes geld
darüber hinaus bietet der haushaltsplan
auch weitere unterstützung und zuschüsse
für wichtige organisationen die unser
demokratisches zusammenleben
und unsere sicherheit fördern sie auch
hand in hand mit den vorhaben der
koalitionsparteien gehen notwendige
rechtliche veränderungen in unserem land
anzustreben dafür möchte ich hier drei
beispiele
herausgreifen erstens hass und hetze im
internet sind täglich präsent
betroffenen wiederum muss aber
orientierung gegeben werden und zynismus
ihnen hilfe zuteil werden wie sie
juristische möglichkeiten nutzen können
die organisation hält setzt genau hier
an bietet kostenlose beratung für
betroffene und die möglichkeit
prozesskosten finanzierung zu beantragen
diese förderung ist unglaublich wichtig
denn das ist keine meinung
zweitens die stärkung unserer
demokratischen zivilgesellschaft und der
kampf gegen rechtsextremismus rassismus
und antisemitismus muss weiter
vorangetrieben werden gerade in den
heutigen zeiten deshalb ist die weitere
förderung der amadeu antonio stiftung
sowie des anne frank zentrums elementar
den rechtsextremismus ist die größte
gefahr für demokratie und rechtsstaat
wenn dieser fertig gewesen
und drittens ein weiteres sehr sehr
wichtiges thema aus einem anderen
bereich in die förderung des vereins
gewaltfreiheit in die zukunft ev bringt
den kampf gegen häusliche gewalt in form
einer non profit app ins digitale
zeitalter
durch diese ff wird betroffenen hilfe
angeboten es wird ihnen hinweisen zu
einrichtungen und frauenhäusern
bereitgestellt und somit einen weg aus
der gewalt aufgezeigt denn hier müssen
wir nicht nur rechtlich bessere weichen
stellen sondern auch darüber hinaus
handeln deshalb begrüße ich diese
förderung sehr
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen 2
ist der umfang des plans durch den
wegfall des verbraucherschutzes was
schon angesprochen wurde etwas kleiner
geworden aber wir wissen auch den
verbraucherschutz bei unseren
kolleginnen und kollegen
umweltministerium sehr gut aufgehoben
bei den themen die noch bei uns liegen
wie die umsetzung der verbandsklage
richtlinie werden wir uns mit herzblut
einbringen
zusammenfassend ist aber zum haushalt
hier im einzelplan 07 zu sagen es viel
fällt ja als er auf den ersten blick
erscheint er enthält hoch aktuelle titel
er ist gerade in unserer jetzigen zeit
wichtig denn wir müssen den rechtsstaat
stärken und schützen und wir brauchen
diese projekte auch um die
verantwortungsvolle politik für die wir
als ampel stehen umzusetzen
dort wo wir verbesserungen der
erweiterungspotenzial sehen werden wir
uns eigentlich einbringen in den
verhandlungen ebenso werden wir weiter
an der fortsetzung der pakt des paktes
für den rechten des digital taxis
arbeiten um der justiz die unterstützung
in personal und ausstattung zukommen zu
lassen die sie braucht ich freue mich
auf die anstehenden beratungen und
verbleiben mit herzlichen dank und freue
mich auf die weitere debatte
sind
beliebte war das in ihrer rede hat sie
unter anderem auch auf hasskriminalität
im internet hingewiesen
dass parlamentarischen kontrollgremiums
die zeit für die wahl ist vorbei es ist
auch sichergestellt dass die mitglieder
des parallel tagen in ältestenrates sie
ihre stimme abgeben konnten gleichwohl
fraglich ist noch ein mitglied des
hauses an sind dass seine stimme nicht
abgegeben hat ich bitte das jetzt zügig
zu vollziehen ich werde in jedem fall
nach dem nächsten redebeitrag dann die
wahl schließen so bundestags
vizepräsidentin petra pau erinnert hier
nochmal an die wahl für das
parlamentarische kontrollgremium das ist
hier ein
gremium das die kontrolle der
nachrichtendienste
dafür zuständig ist diese überwacht zum
beispiel den bundes im nachrichtendienst
für die fdp fraktion spricht jetzt
fabian jakob i
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
sie alle kennen den berühmten dialog aus
dem film der karte
amerigo oder das tochter ist von zwei
jungen männern misshandelt worden das
gericht hat die täter laufen lassen und
nun erscheint von acerra bei mafia paten
don corleone um dort auf anderem wege
genugtuung für geschehenes unrecht zu
erwirken
eine eindringliche künstlerische
darstellung der erkenntnis dass der
rechtsstaat nicht allein aus
gerichtsgebäuden und gesetzbüchern
besteht sondern dass er steht und fällt
mit dem vertrauen das die bürger in ihn
setzen
eng damit verknüpft ist die alte frage
wer eigentlich die wächter bewahrt oder
im vorliegenden kontext die frage wer
die wächter beziehungsweise richter
zuallererst einsetzt damit bin ich bei
dem was das justiz ressort nachdem
regierungsvertrag in dieser wahlperiode
tun soll zitat wir reformieren die wahl
für richter an den obersten
bundesgerichten nicht deutlich wird ob
das bundesverfassungsgericht mit
angesprochen ist dabei wäre gerade dies
dringlich denn wegen seiner besonders
herausragenden rolle im staate wird sich
hier der vertrauensverlust besonders
nachteilig aus dass es diesen gibt wird
hoffentlich niemand bestreiten wollen
ich zitiere die überschrift eines
artikels der im september in der
zeitschrift cicero erschienen ist corona
klima rundfunkbeitrag karlsruhe
entwickelt sich immer mehr zum
erfüllungsgehilfen der politik für
unsere demokratie ist das
brandgefährlich wohin steuert das
bundesverfassungsgericht zitat ende ein
beispiel von vielen nach dem grundgesetz
werden die richter von bundestag und
bundesrat gewählt in der praxis hat eine
gruppe von vier parteien cdu csu spd fdp
und grüne das gericht unter sich
aufgeteilt und besetzt reihum die
richterstelle das ist kein besonderes
geheimnis das kann man wenn man sich
dafür interessiert immer wieder lesen
wir haben bereits einer zurückliegenden
periode den vorschlag gemacht die
richterwahl von den politischen parteien
weg zu verlagern und hin zu einem
wahlgremium das aus der justiz selbst
besetzt wird das ist hier einhellig
abgelehnt worden wenn aber weiterhin die
besetzung des verfassungsgerichts durch
parteipolitiker erfolgen soll dann muss
man über andere reformansätze reden
derzeit geschieht die wahl von
verfassungsrichtern ohne aussprache als
begründung wird angeführt eine
öffentliche erörterung führe zu einer
politisierung des gerichts die aber
verhindert werden müsse dass nun ist
bestenfalls eine lebenslüge schlimmsten
fall bleibt die funktion des
verfassungsgerichts ist per se eine
hochpolitische und es wird von
parteipolitikern besetzt anderswo etwa
in amerika geht man weitaus offener und
dadurch auch ehrlich dort werden die
kandidaten vor ihrer berufung einem von
der demokratischen öffentlichkeit
mitzuverfolgen anhörungs prozess
unterzogen das notwendige vertrauen in
die integrität des gerichts dürfte ein
solches verfahren weitaus eher fördern
als die vorgehensweise wie hierzulande
praktiziert wird letzter satz
das verfahren der richterwahl ist
zentral für den rechtsstaat wir geben
die hoffnung nicht auf dass sinnvolle
reformen auch hier im hause möglich sein
werden vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich komme noch einmal zurück zur
mitglieder des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums die zeit für die wahl
ist vorbei
es noch ein mitglied des hauses anwesend
welches seine stimme nicht ab oder
besser stimme nicht abgegeben hat das
ist nicht der fall ich schließe die wahl
und bitte die schriftführerin und
schriftführer mit der auszählung zu
beginnen das ergebnis der wahl wird
ihnen später bekannt gegeben
damit haben wir nun auch die notwendige
aufmerksamkeit hergestellt zur ersten
rede im deutschen bundestag die der
kollege lukas männer für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen erste corona
pandemie und dann vor einem monat auch
noch der schreckliche angriffskrieg auf
dem kreml
selbstverständlichkeiten sind ebensolche
nicht mehr und es braucht eine politik
die dem gerecht wird eine politik die
anpassungsfähig ist lieber auch
selbstkritisch ist und die vor allen
dingen in diesen schwierigen zeiten sehr
kritisch hinschaut und das geld in das
richtige investiert
gerade im justizbereich kosten die
meisten verbesserungen aber gar kein
geld und das ist das positive an dieser
stelle denn wir brauchen gerade jetzt
eine starke demokratie und dafür eine
leistungsfähige justiz und ein recht auf
höhe der zeit leider finden wir genau
das nicht vor denn im rechtsbereich
liegen 16 jahren reformstau vor uns
liegen 16 jahre hinter uns in dem
gesellschaftlicher wandel gerade nicht
in gesetze geflossen ist und da draußen
leben menschen deren lebensrealität sich
eben nicht in unseren gesetzen
widerspiegelt und genau das stört das
vertrauen ins recht
[Applaus]
in der justiz haben die mitarbeitenden
in und vor der krone pandemie großes
geleistet aber eine leistungsfähige
justiz besteht eben nicht nur aus
aufopfernden mitarbeitenden sondern sie
braucht eine vernünftige ausstattung ein
vernünftiges system
wir sind in der pandemie im bereich der
digitalisierung sehr viel weiter
gekommen als wir uns das vorher gedacht
haben aber trotzdem ist in den
amtsgerichten in der fläche die abkehr
vom faxgerät und von der papierakte
immer noch die große herausforderung da
müssen wir ran
der rückstau von gestern behindert die
entscheidung von morgen und deswegen bin
ich so froh herr bundesminister
buschmann dass wir mit ihnen jemanden
haben der die digitalisierung ernst
meint wie man in ihrem referentenentwurf
von gestern sehen kann und deswegen
gehen wir gemeinsam als ampel dieses
thema an wir geben jetzt schon mehr geld
für digitalisierung der justiz aus und
wir arbeiten am digital pakt für die
justiz um hier voranzugehen
dem aber nicht genug wir wollen für eine
effektive rechtsmittel kontrolle im
strafprozess verhandlungen digital
protokollieren wir wollen den
bürgerinnen und bürgern die möglichkeit
geben ihre ansprüche schnell und
unkompliziert durchzusetzen und mit der
gleichen maßnahme amtsgerichte entlasten
und deswegen wollen wir ermöglichen dass
man klein forderungen digitalen prozess
durchsetzen kann und wenn die kraft
nicht reicht oder der gegner finanziell
zu übermächtig ist wollen wir es
bürgerinnen und bürgern ermöglichen sich
zusammenzuschließen und deswegen stärken
wir den kollektiven rechtsschutz noch
weiter
die digitalisierung ist eine große
chance für eine leistungsfähige justiz
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und jetzt
endlich endlich können wir
gesellschaftliche realität in gesetze
gießen jetzt endlich können wir dafür
sorgen dass nach 16 jahren stillstand
wie ein recht auf höhe der zeit haben
und das ist für uns als fortschritts
koalition die ganz große aufgabe
in keinem bereich wird das so deutlich
wie im familienrecht und deswegen
ermöglichen wir es lesbischen ehepaar
dass wenn ein kind geboren wird sofort
beide mutter sind und deswegen
ermöglichen wir eine elternschaft
anerkennung unabhängig vom geschlecht
und ehe und deswegen ermöglichen wir
menschen für die die ihr nicht das
konstrukt der wahl ist rechtlich
verbindlich verantwortung füreinander zu
übernehmen weil das ist längst
überfällig
nämlich genügen wir schaffen ein
selbstbestimmung gesetz und ja herr
doktor krings wir schaffen 29 10 ich
freue mich auf ihre fachlichen
ausführungen aber das ist längst
überfällig denn wir wollen informationen
ermöglichen und nichts anderes
und weil uns die nachrichten erreichen
ja natürlich wir legalisieren auf
cannabis
denn wenn sich menschen in recht und
gesetz und sich lebensrealitäten in
recht und gesetz wiederfinden dann
stärkt das vertrauen aber ein recht auf
höhe der zeit ist sie nicht nur
politisch zu verstehen sondern noch
dringender denn je auch mit blick auf
die realität da draußen die rede ist von
energie souveränität wir müssen planungs
und genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen
und wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
energiewende aufgrund von guten gesetzen
von klaren auslegungs regelungen und von
vernünftigen gesetzen bis in die fläche
nicht an den gerichten scheitert
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen recht ist
kein selbstzweck es steht im dienste der
bürgerinnen und bürger und genau diesen
schulden wir eine leistungsfähige justiz
und ein recht auf höhe der zeit gehen
wir es gemeinsam an vielen dank
die abgeordneten diskutieren über den
einzelplan 074 das
bundesjustizministerium und es ist nun
mal in der natur dieses ministeriums das
in erster linie ein gesetzgebungs
ministerium ist und auch die anderen
ministerien berät bei der vorbereitung
der rechts gesetzesvorhaben das hier
auch eben eine große palette an themen
angesprochen er wird susanne hier
spricht jetzt hier zum ersten mal im
deutschen bundestag sie ist aus der
unions fraktion und mitglied im
rechtsausschuss
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir diskutieren heute den
betragsmäßig kleinsten haushalt aller
ministerien
wenn wir es vergleichen manch einer
behauptet sogar es wäre die
langweiligste debatte dieser woche die
wir führen dieser meinung bin ich nicht
einmal ein paar projekte der ampel
werfen die diese legislatur vorgesehen
sind da ist zum einen die verbesserung
der qualität der gesetzgebung bei neuen
vorhaben soll frühzeitig und ressort
übergreifend diskutiert werden auch in
neuen formaten die praxis soll mit
einbezogen werden vor allem die
betroffenen und auch die erfahrungen und
bedürfnisse der länder und kommunen
sollen mit einbezogen werden das begrüße
ich auf 400 prozent aber wie sieht denn
die umsetzung in der praxis aus nehmen
wir zum beispiel die einführung der
sektoralen impfpflicht zum ende des
letzten jahres
ich kann mir schwer vorstellen dass hier
eine frühzeitige einbeziehung der
betroffenen erfolgt ist der
verantwortlichen in den einrichtungen
der pflegerinnen und pfleger der
kommunen und länder anders kann ich es
mir nicht erklären dass die diskussion
um eine durchsetzbarkeit dieser
impfpflicht erst wochen nach abschluss
des gesetzgebungsverfahrens fahrt
aufgenommen hat hier haben sie noch viel
luft nach oben um ihre eigenen ansprüche
zu erfüllen
weiter
wollen sie den gesetzen eine synopse mit
beifügen das heißt der aktuellen
rechtslage
auch die neue geänderte rechtslage
gegenüber stehen für die anwender in der
praxis wie zb anwälte steuerberater oder
auch behörden wäre das eine wirkliche
erleichterung
bisher kann ich davon aber nichts
feststellen
inhaltlich
kündigt das ministerium an die unter
anderem die größte reform des
familienrechts
einzuführen das wohl des kindes soll
hierbei zentral sein heißt es im
koalitionsvertrag
es geht um die ausweitung des kleinen
sorgerechts es geht um änderungen im
unterhalts- und um und es geht auch um
die verantwortungsgemeinschaft
das sind themen die millionen von
menschen bei uns im land betreffen trägt
man aber nach einem zeitlichen
umsetzungs zeitpunkt so kann das
ministerium keine nennen
stattdessen kümmert man sich mit
hochdruck um die abschaffung des
paragraphen 219 a strafgesetzbuch
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ganz
ehrlich ist dass unser größtes und
vorträge ist das problem das wir
momentan zu lösen haben
die abschaffung des werbeverbots für den
schwangerschaftsabbruch und herr
minister ich kann gut verstehen dass so
schnelle erfolge wollen und in der
legislatur sehr früh ihr lieblingsthema
durchsetzen das kann man so machen aber
ich meine sie setzen die prioritäten
völlig falsch
ich hoffe dass das ministerium
bei allen vorhaben die kommen über den
tellerrand hinaus sieht und wirklich die
bedürfnisse der praxis mit in die
gesetzgebungs initiativen mit einbezieht
die betroffenen würden es ihnen danken
seien sie sich versichert wir werden
alle projekte ganz genau beobachten und
werden uns weiterhin tatkräftig mit
einbringen haben sie herzlichen dank
susanne hilgers ihre erste rede und die
hat sie noch frei gehalten das fällt
schon auf werden hier jemand ohne zettel
nach vorne geht und sich auch noch
innerhalb der redezeit und zum schluss
kommt johannes richter spricht jetzt für
den
spd-minister buschmann liebe zu kennen
und zu unserer haushaltsberatungen
werden natürlich und auch zurecht
überlagert vom brutalen angriffskrieg
von putin auf die ukraine wir sind alle
immer noch entsetzt aber wir stehen ganz
fest an der seite der ukraine und eines
ist dabei klar das will ich gerade in
einer rechts politischen debatte
ausdrücklich auch so sagen diesen
brutalen überfall den dulden wir nicht
es muss die stärke des rechts gelten und
nicht das recht des stärkeren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und gerade in der rechtspolitik und auch
mit diesem haushalt da werden wir uns
dafür einsetzen dass konflikte und
streitigkeiten gerade auf
internationaler ebene
friedlich gelöst werden und zwar in
rechtsstaatlichen verfahren wir machen
mit diesem haushalt viel zum beispiel
unterstützen wir wichtige internationale
einrichtungen wie die wto den
internationalen seegerichtshof oder auch
ganz besonders wichtig für uns die
rechtsstaatliche aufbauarbeit der
gesellschaft für internationale
rechtliche zusammenarbeit also wir
leisten mit diesem haushalt wirklich
einen beitrag dafür dass solche
konflikte auf international friedlich
gelöst werden kolleginnen und kollegen
und wir nehmen uns rechtspolitisch auch
in dieser wahlperiode sehr viel vor wir
haben uns einiges vorgenommen
dazu gehört es dass wir im strafrecht
genau prüfen welche vorschrift brauchen
wir überhaupt noch denn wir wollen eine
effektive kriminalpolitik und dann
gehört es eben dazu dass wir endlich den
paragrafen 219 a für den es kein
praktisches bedürfnis mehr geht
streichen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das will ich hier deutlich sagen wenn
frauen und schwieriger lage sind da
brauchen sie schnell und einfach zugang
zu informationen und es kann einfach
nicht sein dass ärzte
schwangerschaftsabbrüche vornehmen
dürfen darüber aber nicht sachlich
informieren dürfen und deswegen werden
wir diesen widerspruch auflösen in den
übrigen wird die werbung für
schwangerschafts abbrüche auch nicht
zulässig seien es gibt weiterhin das
ärztliche standesrecht also schneiden
wir diesen alten zopf endlich ab es ist
gut dass wir als eines der ersten
projekte in der ampelkoalition diese
nicht mehr notwendige vorschrift des 219
a endlich streichen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
ich wusste doch wer es macht ja ich war
kollege wenn wir die diskussion schon
öfter geführt und wissen auch so wir
stehen und die argumente sind auch mehr
machen ausgetauscht
ich möchte aber dann doch hier nochmal
fragen das sind ja in der rechts debatte
und zu dem thema 219 hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ja auch
ausführliche urteile gemacht und da wäre
jetzt meiner frage das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt das
ungeborene kind entwickelte sich von
anfang an als mensch und nicht zum
menschen es hat von anfang an
menschenwürde und lebensrecht und das
konnten in der diskussion die wir hier
führen also doch sehr kurz und ich würde
jetzt mal ihre haltung so und wir
verlassen die debatte jetzt denn nun ist
die pressekonferenz von
aixtron haben gerade den sondern
der führungsspitze der markt vor beendet
um die größte gefahr für unsere
sicherheit in einer generation zu
besprechen erklärt von präsident gut
hingegen die ukraine die menschen in der
ukraine leisten widerstand voller mut
und kämpfen für ihre freiheit und ihre
zukunft wir stehen an ihrer seite
präsident seelands gehört zu uns
gesprochen mit einer leidenschaftlichen
botschaft er hat den nato bündnispartner
gedanken für unsere umfangreiche hilfe
und hat darauf hingewiesen dass es
wichtig ist noch mehr militär hilft zu
geben die politischen führer der nato
haben heute vereinbart dass wir weitere
hilfe an die ukraine liefern werden wir
werden
die lebensmittelskandale durch müssen
aufgedeckt worden gesehen wie wichtig es
ist dass es mutige menschen geht die
missstände aufdecken und deswegen zum
schutz für verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher wollen wir die eu
whistleblower richtigen schnell umsetzen
wenn jemand so mutig ist dass er
persönliche nachteile riskiert dann
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass ihm nicht
gekündigt werden kann dass er keinen
schadenersatz bezahlen muss dass seine
rechtsstellung sicher ist und deswegen
wollen wir diese richtlinie möglichst
schnell umsetzen liebe kolleginnen
politik
und werden auch den kollektiven
rechtsschutz in deutschland verbessern
indem er die verbandsklage richtlinie
rasch umsetzen wollen das gibt den
bürgerinnen und bürgern die möglichkeit
gemeinsam in einer gemeinschaft ihre
rechte umzusetzen das stärkt die
rechtsposition der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher
das kann die justiz auch entlassen uns
ein wichtiges ziel und vor allem es wird
dann recht bekommen der recht hat und
das schnell und kostengünstiger als es
heute der fall ist auch das ein ganz
wichtiges projekt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und die besten gesetze bringen
bekanntlich nichts wenn wir in der
justiz kein personal haben zu wenig
richterinnen und richter die die gesetze
dann auch anwenden und gerade deshalb
ist es ein großer erfolg gewesen dass
wir in der vergangenen wahlperiode über
2000 richterstellen und staatsanwalt in
den ställen erschaffen haben mit 200
millionen euro vom bund da waren wir
eine zweite auflage wir wollen einen
weiteren pakt für den rechtsstaat auch
mit einem klaren schwerpunkt auf die
digitalisierung und sich auch
ausdrücklich an merken will wir müssen
hier beraten wie wir gerade beim folge
personal in den geschäftsstellen auch
wenn mehr personal sorgen das ist der
maschinenraum der justiz und auch um
diese mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter
wollen wir uns kümmern liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und
wir freuen uns sehr dass wir mit dem
forum recht in leipzig und in karlsruhe
eine ganz wichtige einrichtung
geschaffen haben einen ort wo für den
rechtsstaat und die große vorteile einer
parlamentarischen demokratie geworben
werden kann ein herzliches dankeschön an
alle die sich in karlsruhe und in
leipzig hier engagieren dass wir hier im
haushalt 3,5 millionen euro vorgesehen
haben ist glaube ich auch ein ganz
wichtiges zeichen für einen starken
rechtsstaat in deutschland liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und wir müssen
die planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
in deutschland deutlich beschleunigen es
geht nicht mehr dass wir viele jahre auf
baurecht für windkraftanlagen für
solarparks oder für bahnstrecken warten
müssen und dazu gehört es insbesondere
auch dass wir die verwaltungsgerichte
personell gut ausstatten und an der
stelle darf sich schon erklärungsbedarf
von meiner fraktion anmelden warum dann
ausgerechnet beim
bundesverwaltungsgericht eine deutliche
reduzierung der personalausgaben jetzt
vorgesehen ist darüber wollen wir in den
anstehenden beratungen durchaus noch mal
sprechen alles in allem zeigt der
haushalt und die vielen gesetzesvorhaben
der ampel dass die rechtspolitik eine
ganz wichtige rolle in der
ampelkoalition spielt und dass wir mit
vielen ganz konkreten verbesserungen für
die bürgerinnen und bürger hier
aufwarten können vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der abgeordnete tobias
peter für die auf die fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr gerne kollegen
liebe zuschauer man kann das einmal froh
sein dass das justizministerium unser
der ampel an die fdp gefallen ist dann
sicher hätte es noch weitaus gruseliger
kommen können konnten wir bei den reden
heute wieder eindrucksvoll beobachten
die budgetierung
die budgetierung an sich ist bekanntlich
wenig spektakulär in diesem kleinen teil
haushalt bei den ganzen freigiebigkeit
die an kanzler scholz andernorts noch
absegnen wird kann eine sparsame
haushaltsführung im justizministerium
leider ohnehin nichts mehr groß reißen
fdp hin muss man her immerhin die
steigenden einnahmen des patent- und
markenamtes sind natürlich erfreulich es
wurde schon erwähnt und auch die von
minister buschmann geforderten internet
streifen auf sozialen plattformen werden
den bereich der länder oder zumindest
des innenministeriums fallen wenn denn
überhaupt stellen geschaffen werden und
nicht die polizeiwache buxtehude jetzt
auch noch einen facebook-account dazu
einrichten muss den digital services act
den sich der minister anscheinend herr
angenommen hat um sich nur auf ihn zu
verlassen werden wir natürlich noch
genau unter die lupe nehmen es kann
nämlich nicht sein dass immer mehr auf
das sogenannte europäische ebene
geschaufelt wird insbesondere bei einem
themenbereich denn die beiden anderen
ampel parteien lange per netz dg mit
schöner deutscher gründlichkeit selber
regeln wollten und vielleicht sollte
analog zu den cyber streifen die
angesprochenen auch einmal verstärkte
digitale kompetenz der rechtsprechung
gestärkt werden und damit meine ich
nicht unbedingt die digitale
aktenführung oder dergleichen
da hinken wir derart hinterher das wohl
erst ein kompletter generationswechsel
eintreten muss auch wenn die regierung
hier von 2026 herum fabuliert nein
schulungen in allen belangen digitaler
sachverhalte werden für die
bundesrichter dringend anzuraten für die
länder ebene finden sich dann vielleicht
sogar der ein oder andere synergieeffekt
gern auch innerhalb der deutschen
richterakademie dadurch könnten nicht
zuletzt für den bereich der krypto
währungen hanebüchene und wirtschafts
schädliche urteile vermieden werden und
ja immerhin es wird bei den gießkannen
förderungen ein interessantes projekt zu
rechtlichen implikationen der block
chain mit 300.000 euro bedacht und die
250.000 euro für die amadeu antonio
stiftung hingegen werden deutlich
sinnvoller angelegt wenn man diese
ebenfalls auf praktische und
zukunftsgerichtete themenfelder umleiten
würde
abschließend hoffe ich abschließend
hoffe ich dass die beratungsfunktion des
justizressorts innerhalb des kabinetts
mit nachdruck wahrgenommen wird so
könnten die schlimmsten ideologischen
auswüchse der ampel operativ aber
vielleicht auch haushalt herisch
vermieden werden viel glück bei dieser
süße force arbeit
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun die kollegin bei
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die justiz wird
auch dadurch entlastet dass wir uns das
was wir vorgenommen haben tatsächlich
jetzt starten indem sie nämlich
liberalisieren indem wir legalisieren
indem wir entkriminalisieren und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der cdu 219
war erst der anfang
denn die entkriminalisierung
vom fahren ohne fahrschein heißt eben
auch tatsächlich menschen in den blick
zu nehmen die in gefängnissen landen
weil sie nicht über die mittel verfügen
und man könnte tatsächlich viel reden
über die cannabis legalisierung weil sie
so immer fällig ist dass ich neulich
gehört habe auch der anteil der menschen
die kiffen bei der cdu habe zugenommen
meine damen und herren wenn das nicht
bedeutet dass
im deutschen bundestag angekommen ist
und wir alle gemeinsam die verantwortung
dafür haben ja dann weiß ich es auch
nicht liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
wir werden nicht nur das strafgesetzbuch
and muttern wir werden uns auch die
verfahren anschauen wir werden uns die
verfahren anschauen und es gab einige
die hier heute gesagt haben das
dokumentieren gerade mit blick auf die
gräuel die derzeit nicht weit von uns
hier in der ukraine stattfinden das muss
dokumentiert werden wir haben in
deutschland die erfahrung gemacht dass
wir gräueltaten aus syrien hier vor
deutsche gerichte gestellt haben dass
meine damen und herren sollte weiterhin
unser anspruch bleiben und dafür
brauchen wir unterstützung
dass diejenigen die opfer werden von
diesen angriffen die bei uns hier in
berlin in deutschland ankommen als
geflüchtete das dass diejenigen sind die
ihre peiniger demnächst vor gericht
überführen können durch ihre auf
zeugenaussagen meine damen und herren
und da sind wir noch nicht gut genug
aufgestellt da müssen wir digitalisieren
wir müssen besser dokumentieren und ich
sage ihnen wir müssen auch in den
prozessen die demokratie schützen sie
haben es bestimmt alle mitbekommen
sowohl die npd als auch die af die
machen eine kampagne um die chefin
wahlen im nächsten jahr zu nutzen um in
die herzkammer wenn man so will unseres
rechtsstaates menschen zu setzen von
denen wir ja nicht erst seit der
gerichtsentscheidung in köln wissen dass
das die feinde unserer demokratie sind
meine damen und herren
deswegen werden wir den pakt für den
rechtsstaat fortschreiben und so
ausstatten dass das gelingt was für uns
alle entscheidend ist der rechtsstaat
ist eben nur so gut wie er vertrauen
seitens der bevölkerung genießt und
dieses vertrauen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das müssen wir als gesetzgeber
auch immer im blick haben wenn wir
gesetze machen
aktuell reden wir viel über sanktionen
gegenüber oligarchen und da will ich mal
ganz deutlich machen als eine die in
ihrem wahlkreis menschen hat die im
mietrecht erwartungen an dieser ampel
koalition haben wir müssen wissen wie
die häuser gehören wir müssen wissen wer
hinter diesen immobilien steht damit wir
wirklich sanktionen umsetzen können
meine damen und herren und da ist es
mittlerweile schon so dass wir uns
fragen lassen müssen warum schaut ihr
eigentlich nicht so genau hin es ist
euch egal mit welchem geld waffen
bezahlt werden die gegen menschen in der
ukraine eingesetzt werden und für meine
fraktion und ich glaube für die mehrheit
dieses hauses kann ich sagen es ist uns
nicht egal wir wollen das bekämpfen wir
wollen verschleierung verschleierung von
eigentum bei immobilien und in anderen
bereichen bekämpfen fangen wir gemeinsam
damit an mit einem immobilien register
das tatsächlich transparent ist und aus
weiß wer dort eigentlich schmutziges
geld für schmutzige kriege ausgibt meine
damen und herren
und damit wir uns heute
in bezug auf den haushalt
wirklich verabreden deutlich zu machen
dass uns der shop der schutz der
chefinnen und schöffen wichtig ist
sollten wir während der
haushaltsberatungen gemeinsam
miteinander reden wie wir die kommunen
und die länder dabei unterstützen können
dass diese verfassungsfeinde dort nicht
reinkommen und da reichen mir ihre
bisherigen vorschläge noch nicht er muss
herr buschmann da müssen wir noch mal
miteinander reden
[Applaus]
zu ihrer ersten rede im deutschen
bundestag erhält nun die kollegin
franziska hofmann das wohl
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister buschmann liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit einer
knappen milliarde euro bildete
einzelplan 07 nur einen kleinen teil des
bundeshaushalts ab das haben wir heute
schon mehrmals gesagt diese summe
spiegelt allerdings nicht seine relevanz
wieder der etat des bmj ist für die
judikative auf bundesebene und somit für
eine funktionierende gewaltenteilung von
immenser bedeutung
die vergangenen jahre haben wir mit
dieser unionsgeführten regierung
bewiesen mit einer vernünftig
ausgestatteten strafverfolgung auf
bundesebene leisten wir einen großen
beitrag zur sicherheit gerechtigkeit und
freiheit in unserem land
ich möchte dies auch anhand einiger
zahlen konkretisieren in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode haben wir eine
substanzielle steigerung und stärkung
des haushalts erreichen können 2017
haben wir begonnen mit 838 millionen
euro und 2021 waren wir bei 957
millionen euro ein bereich möchte ich
besonders hervorheben wir haben aus
gemeinsamer überzeugung in der letzten
legislaturperiode den etat des
generalbundesanwalts sogar verdoppelt
aufgrund der äußeren und inneren
gefahrenlage im staatsschutz war diese
finanzielle aufwertung auch bitter nötig
nicht nur rechtsextremistische
übergriffe sondern auch islamistische
und linksextremistische anschläge haben
in den vergangenen jahren deutlich
zugenommen jetzt beobachten wir aber
dass die ampel koalition diese erfolge
riskiert mehrere meiner vorredner aus
der koalition haben den stellenwert des
generalbundesanwalts ja sogar
hervorgehoben sie aber senken in ihrem
entwurf
2022 den personal etat des
generalbundesanwalts gegenüber dem
entwurf der vorgängerregierung um 15
prozent in den personalkosten
herr minister das ist unverantwortlich
und zwar steht im koalitionsvertrag und
sie forderten es heute ja auch
mehrheitlich aus der koalition dass sie
den pakt für den rechtsstaat fortführen
und ihn ja sogar um einen digital packt
recht erweitern wollen im haushalt aber
finden wir dazu nichts übrigens in
keinem einzelplan dabei ist gerade die
gemeinsam mit den ländern vereinbarte
stärkung der judikative eine der
wichtigsten säulen unseres rechtsstaats
und damit unserer gesellschaftsordnung
und demokratie vor dem hintergrund
vielfältige herausforderungen und
zusätzlichen belastungen wie der
verfolgung von kinderpornografie hass
und hetze im netz der kollege händel hat
es beschrieben und der organisierten
kriminalität ist eine funktionierende
gerichtsbarkeit essentiell setzen sie
das nicht leichtfertig aufs spiel
ein weiterer wichtiger punkt ist die bis
20 26 umzusetzende digitalisierung des
rechtsverkehrs seit vielen jahren
arbeiten insbesondere die länder an
deren umsetzung aber auch ihr haus herr
minister buschmann hat hier noch einige
hausaufgaben zu erledigen sie haben den
digitalmarkt recht in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag angekündigt kollege
liefert ihnen früheren auch noch einmal
angepriesen ich bin sehr gespannt wann
sie ihm verhandeln wollen und was da
überhaupt drin stehen soll aber sie und
ihr haus könnten bereits jetzt einiges
für mehr effizienz effektivität und
rechtsschutz in deutschland tun ein paar
beispiele aus dem bereich der justice im
rahmen der ag die justice 2 wird von den
ländern laufend verbesserungsbedarf
hinsichtlich einzelner regelung zur e
akte und zum elektronischen
rechtsverkehr identifiziert hier hat der
bund die regelungskompetenz
ich greife nur drei punkte auf die
besonders wichtig sind die sie dringend
angehen müssen erstens die anpassung der
materiellen vom erfordernis an das
prozessrecht damit zum beispiel
kündigungen in anwalts schriftsätzen
weiterhin möglich bleiben und keinen
zusatzaufwand auf anwalts um gerichts
weiter vorne
zweitens die schaffung einer
rechtsgrundlage zur festlegung eines 1
etliche nackten übermittlung standards
damit sichergestellt ist dass die
verschiedenen akteure elektronischer
akten ohne größeren aufwand
untereinander übermitteln können und
drittens die vermeidung zusätzlichen
aufwands durch sinnvolle gestaltung des
elektronischen rechtsverkehrs mit dem
gerichtsvollzieher
durch den wegfall von schriftform
erfordernissen sie gelungen ausdrucken
versenden und wieder einscannen gibt es
wirklich einfache möglichkeiten von
effizienzgewinnen ganz ohne zusätzlich
erforderlicher ausgaben und das ist uns
haushalt seien immer besonders lieb
und wir haben hier sogar einige
einsparpotenziale sowohl in der
verwaltung als auch auf seiten der
wirtschaft unter bürgerinnen und bürger
herr minister legen sie in ihrem
haushalt nach und legen sie vor allem
los herzlichen dank für die
[Applaus]
das wort hat herr kollege kw mansouri
für die spd frau zu
frau präsidentin herr bundesminister
meine damen und herren wir sind mit dem
anspruch in diese legislatur gestalte
gestartet unser land zukunftsfest zu
machen und das bundesministerium der
justiz spielt eine zentrale rolle dabei
die rechtlichen voraussetzungen für den
fortschritt zu stellen als
ampelkoalition haben wir uns vorgenommen
rechtspolitische vorhaben umzusetzen
auch wenn es den rechtsaußen nicht passt
die die würde aller menschen in den
mittelpunkt stellen und die vielfalt in
unserer gesellschaft anerkennt meine
damen und herren
auch reform des kindschaftsrechts
modernisierung des abstimmungs rechts
des familien- und personenstandsrecht
oder die stärkung von
diskriminierungsschutz die liste von
rechts politischen vorhaben dieser
koalition ist lang das erwarten die
menschen von uns und dieser haushalt
stellt die finanziellen voraussetzungen
dafür dass wir das auch schaffen werden
meine damen und herren
für viele der von mir genannten vorhaben
haben zivilgesellschaftliche
organisationen lange gekämpft für eine
starke zivilgesellschaft dass es motor
für gesellschaftlichen fortschritt und
modernisierung eine starke
zivilgesellschaft leistet wertvolle
bildungs und aufklärungsarbeit und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass im justiz
haushalt zuschüsse für projekte
vorgesehen sind wie beispielsweise für
das projekt rassismus antisemitismus
rechtsextremismus
stärkung von strafverfolgungen
opferschutz des deutschen instituts für
menschenrechte oder für die kampagne 100
jahre frauen in juristischen berufen des
deutschen juristinnenbundes oder die
bundesstiftung magnus hirschfeld die mit
ihren bildungs und
forschungsprojekten die diskriminierung
der sexuellen und geschlechtlichen
identität entgegenwirkt meine damen und
herren
jeder mensch ist in seiner
einzigartigkeit besonders und verdient
respekt und anerkennung diejenigen die
sich dafür stark machen verdienen unsere
unterstützung und neben den
gesellschaftspolitischen fortschritten
stellen wird in der rechtspolitik auch
die weichen für den sozial ökologischen
umbau unseres landes oder wie der
bundesfinanzminister es zu beginn der
beratung formuliert hat für nachhaltiges
wachstum meine damen und herren der
ausbau einer sauberen
verkehrsinfrastruktur der erneuerbaren
energien sie sind eine versicherung für
folgende generationen und das bedeutet
nachhaltige wertschöpfung und neue
arbeitsplätze jemand muss diese dinge
konzipieren jemand muss sie bauen jemand
muss sie warten dabei fließen millionen
in die sozialkassen an steuern an den
fiskus zurück dass wohlstand der unser
land stärker macht und unsere zukunft
besser meine damen und herren
stellen sie sich großen sind investoren
mit gewissen sie wollen 25 millionen
euro in saubere windenergie investieren
sie kommen zum anwalt zum beispiel zu
mir und er sagt den das dauert sechs
jahre bis ihr windrad gebaut ist sie
müssen eine ausschreibung gewinnen sie
werden tausende von euro in das projekt
stecken bis sie die erste kilowattstunde
strom verkauft haben sie werden wälder
roden für ihre antragsunterlagen die
rechtliche abschätzung unübersichtlich
und unberechenbar vielleicht wird ihr
windrad gar nicht gebaut sie waren
frustriert nach hause und wenn wir nicht
gerade niedrig zins hätten stecken sie
ihre 25 millionen lieber in ein sparbuch
meine damen und herren es
braucht mehr tempo bei planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren nicht als
selbstzweck sondern weil der
demokratische rechtsstaat in der lage
sein muss die großen herausforderungen
unserer zeit auch anzupacken meine damen
und herren
planungs beschleunigung ist ermöglichung
recht und es legt den grundstein für
milliarden investitionen für öffentliche
aber vor allem für private und ist damit
notwendige voraussetzungen dafür dass
wir steuereinnahmen in der zukunft haben
steuereinnahmen mit denen wir hier viel
gutes in diesem haus bewirken werden
und es wird dabei unter anderem darum
gehen das papier akten nicht von büro zu
büro wandern dass die behörde die selbe
einwendung nicht fünfmal prüft sondern
einmal dass sie keine
habilitationsschrift zur vogelkunde
gelesen haben müssen um die risiken
eines windrads für die rotmilane
population selbst recht sicher
einschätzen zu können und dass wir
gerichte auch so ausstatten dass sie
zügig urteile sprechen und verfahren
abschließen können der kollege hat das
gesagt darüber werden wir reden müssen
meine damen und herren und wir müssen
das schaffen
wir müssen das schaffen weil die
menschen sonst das vertrauen in unsere
staatsform verlieren wir brauchen
effektiven rechtsschutz aber wir
brauchen auch effiziente
entscheidungsstrukturen meine damen und
herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
eine zentrale säule von wehrhaften
demokratie
darüber ist viel gesprochen worden in
den letzten tagen ist ein
handlungsfähiger und starker rechtsstaat
das alles ist unendlich kostbar und
deswegen können und müssen wir uns das
leisten ich danke ihm für die
aufmerksamkeit
weitere wortmeldungen zu diesem
einzelplan liegen nicht vor wir kommen
zu dem geschäftsbereich des
bundesministeriums des innern und für
heimat
ich bitte zügig die plätze einzunehmen
so ich bitte platz zu nehmen und den
korrekten sitz der mund nasen bedeckung
auf mund und nase zu überprüfen
wir fahren in der aussprache fort das
wort hat die bundesministerin des innern
und für heimat
nancy faeser
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren heute vor einem monat
hat putin mit seinem furchtbaren
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine begonnen millionen von menschen
fliehen vor gewalt und zerstörung sie
suchen zuflucht auch in unserem land
viele bürgerinnen und bürger zeigen sich
solidarisch und helfen sehr aktiv ihnen
allen gebührt mein großer respekt und
dank
auch der staat beweist in der jetzigen
lage seine handlungsfähigkeit kommunen
länder und der bund leisten in dieser
herausfordernden situation einen grossen
humanitären kraftakt unsere haupt
augenmerk ist dabei die bestmöglichste
versorgung unterbringung und verteilung
der geflüchteten in deutschland und in
der gesamten eu jetzt geht es darum den
historischen schulterschluss den wir
durch die gemeinsame aufnahmen der eu
erreicht haben in praktisches handeln
umzusetzen
das hat meine oberste priorität
wir etablieren bus und zugverbindungen
um geflüchtete aus polen und deutschland
nach frankreich zu bringen und von dort
in andere eu-staaten mein dank gilt
ausdrücklich frankreich die einen harten
mit uns gemeinsam eingerichtet haben
nach bordeaux nach dijon und lyon
wir haben von anfang an gemeinsam mit
dem bundesverkehrsministerium eine
stabsstelle für die koordinierung der
verteilung der ankommenden eingerichtet
täglich sind in unserem auftrag
sonderzüge und busse unterwegs auch bei
der registrierung unterstützt mein haus
die länder sowohl personell als auch
materiell um den geflüchteten eine
zentrale vertrauenswürdige digitale
anlaufstelle in deutschland bereit zu
stellen haben wir kurzfristig das hilfs
portal germany for uk entwickelt um
darüber hinaus die erste orientierung in
deutschland zu erleichtern öffnen wir
die integrations und sprachkurse für
schutzsuchende aus der ukraine
und ich will betonen was mir persönlich
besonders am herzen liegt und deswegen
haben wir den schutz dort auch sehr
verstärkt ist der schutz der
geflüchteten frauen die hier in
deutschland ankommen ihnen gilt unsere
gesamte aufmerksamkeit
auch die beschaffung von hilfsgütern und
medizinischem material für die ukraine
und angrenzende staaten haben für mich
eine hohe priorität
mein besonderer dank und ich denke unser
aller gilt den einsatzkräften des thw
der bundespolizei und des bamf dank
ihrer engagierten arbeit und des großen
engagements und das will ich hier noch
einmal betonen die ehrenamtlichen
helferinnen und helfer und der
hilfsorganisation kann man gar nicht
hoch genug einschätzen deswegen noch
einmal ein ausdrückliches dankeschön an
alle gerade die ehrenamtliche kräfte or
in unserem land
der überfall russlands auf die ukraine
ist eine zäsur und wir müssen unsere
sicherheit auch im lichte neuer
realitäten sehen deswegen möchte ich
klar vorweg sagen das wird auch
zusätzliche finanzielle belastungen nach
sich ziehen die in diesem haushalt noch
nicht berücksichtigt sind er ist
ausdrücklich sagen weil ich denke hier
insbesondere an weitere investitionen
die erforderlich sein werden jetzt in
den zivilschutz den grenzschutz die
innere sicherheit und vor allen dingen
und das hat oberste priorität den
integrationsbereich aber auch die
deutsche cyber
sicherheitsarchitektur werden wir weiter
stärken wir haben alle schutzmaßnahmen
gegen russische attacken hochgefahren
kommen wir nun zum vorliegenden
haushaltsentwurf das bundesministerium
des innern und für heimat hat sich für
die nächsten
vier jahre hohe ziele gesetzt wir wollen
sicherheit im wandel gewährleisten und
bringen das voran was wir als
fortschritts koalition uns vorgenommen
haben wir wollen sicherheit für alle
gewährleisten unsere demokratie stärken
und entschieden gegen jede form von
extremismus vorgehen
wir wollen deutschland zu einem
vielfältigen einwanderungsland machen
menschen integrieren aber auch mit aller
härte straftäter und gefährden ihre
heimatländer zurück führen wir wollen
eine bürgernahe transparente und
digitale verwaltung schaffen krisen
meistern und auf katastrophen
vorbereitet sein und ich will den
zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft
fördern und mich für gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse stark machen und beim
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhang kommt
vor allen dingen auch dem sport eine
große rolle zu
der vorliegende haushaltsentwurf schafft
dafür die basis wir stärken mit
zusätzlichen mitteln und neun stellen
die innere sicherheit in unserem land
der haushaltsentwurf sieht für den
einzelplan das bmi ein gesamtvolumen von
rund 15 milliarden euro vor das ist ein
plus von 1,6 milliarden euro im
vergleich zum ursprünglichen finanzplan
und das sind
1660 stellen mehr für sicherheit
integration und zusammenhalt
und ich kann den bürgerinnen und bürgern
versichern dieses geld ist gut
investiert
wir werden rechtsextremismus
linksextremismus und islamismus
frühzeitig und entschlossen bekämpfen
politische bildung prävention und
entschlossenes handeln unserer
sicherheitsbehörden
gehören aus meiner sicht eng zusammen
und das habe ich auch in mit dem
aktionsplan gegen rechtsextremismus
dargestellt auf der einen seite
präventive maßnahmen auf der anderen
seite die ganze härte des rechtsstaates
wir nehmen zusätzliche gelder in die
hand um unsere sicherheit zu behörden
besser auszustatten und auf dem stand
der technik zu halten
als zeichen der wertschätzung unserer
polizistinnen und polizisten wollen wir
die ruhegehalts fähigkeit der polizei zu
lage wieder einführen das bedeutet für
mich echte wertschätzung keine
sonntagsreden und ich finde das haben
die polizeibeamtinnen und beamten in
unserem land mehr als verdient
wir werden aber auch dass bundespolizei
gesetzen will ihren wie investieren in
den ausbau des netzes des bundes und in
die it-sicherheit wir wollen integration
von anfang an das ist ein schlüssel für
den zusammenhalt unserer gesellschaft
wir bauen die integrationskurse aus und
verbessern das kursangebot wir setzen
die förderung von jüdischen
einrichtungen
konsequent fort und bekämpfen
antisemitismus mit aller entschiedenheit
zu einem modernen staat gehört eine
bürokratiearme transparente und digitale
verwaltung das müssen bürgerinnen bürger
in ihrem alltag aber auch spüren deshalb
sehen wir erhebliche mittel für die
digitalisierung von
verwaltungsdienstleistungen vor mit dem
haushaltsentwurf setzen wir außerdem
sehr wichtige akzente im bereich des
bevölkerungsschutzes und der
katastrophenhilfe wir müssen künftig
besser auf mögliche krisen katastrophen
und klimafolgen vorbereitet sein das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe wurde mit dem
konjunkturpaket des haushaltes 20 21 mit
zusätzlichen sachmitteln in höhe von
fast 100 millionen bereits erheblich
gestärkt zu dem kampf 50 stellen hinzu
mit dem jetzt vorgeschlagenen haushalt
satteln wir darauf noch einmal auf das
bbk soll für 2022 insgesamt nochmals 112
stellen und 19 5 millionen mehr erhalten
das sind sogar 32 millionen euro mehr
als geplant und wenn ich ihnen das sagen
darf er wolle angesichts der aktuellen
lage freue ich mich auf ihre
unterstützung in einem ergänzungs
haushalt da noch mal drauf zu satteln
meine damen und herren wir
bekennen uns zu unserer
schutzverantwortung wenn menschen vor
krieg und verfolgung fliehen es ist
richtig dass wir die ausgaben für
humanitäre aufnahmen erhöhen deshalb
unterstütze ich auch die beabsichtigte
stärkung des bundeshaushalts im
ergänzungs haushalt auch in dieser
hinsicht meine damen und herren wir
wollen die gesellschaftliche kraft des
sports stärken dazu setzen wir auf
integration und inklusion im sport aber
wir fördern natürlich auch den
spitzensport und haben deshalb auch dort
die mittel erhöht und die spitzensport
reform steht weiterhin an unter anderem
wollen wir die große ereignisse wie die
nationalen spiele der special olympics
22 und die special olympics world games
unterstützen und wir wollen starb darauf
freuen wir uns alle die fußball-em 2024
in deutschland zu einem großen fest des
sportlers machen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir haben uns viel vorgenommen und ich
möchte dass mit ihnen gemeinsam umsetzen
mein dank für die vertrauensvolle
zusammenarbeit gilt allen
berichterstatter und berichterstatter im
haushaltsausschuss ich darf besonders
familie schäfer dr thorsten lieb und
natürlich martin gerster dabei erwähnen
herzlichen dank ich werbe für ihre
unterstützung die herausforderungen sind
sehr groß dieser krieg mit einer europa
zeigt äußere und innere sicherheit
gehören zusammen gerade jetzt müssen wir
sie stärken vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin andrea
lindholz für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
investitionen in die sicherheit sie sind
nicht immer populär aber dieses aber sie
sind zwingend notwendig und deshalb hat
auch schon die letzte bundesregierung
unter der führung der union in den
letzten acht jahren massiv in die innere
sicherheit investiert wir haben den
bundeshaushalt
von 5,9 milliarden euro im jahr 2014
bis zum vergangenen jahr auf knapp 15
milliarden euro fast in deutschland zu
einem vielfältigen
einwanderungsland machen unter anderem
mit sport den sie stärken möchte aber
auch extremismus bekämpfen und in
politische bildung in prävention
investieren mittlerweile sind wir jetzt
schon in der aussprache
und da können wir jetzt auch gleich
reinhören andrea lindholz spricht gerade
die stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der unionsfraktion
brauchen wir neben geld auch weitsicht
und wir brauchen auch die bereitschaft
führungsverantwortung zu sehen und zu
übernehmen und das liebe frau ministerin
vermisse ich an der einen oder anderen
stelle
in ihrem aktionsplan rechtsextremismus
da betreiben sie vor allem eines und das
ist augenwischerei denn vieles aus dem
plan hatten wir schon in der letzten
legislaturperiode auf den weg gebracht
ich nenne hier das förderprogramm
demokratie im netz oder auch den
lagebericht zu rechtsextremisten im
öffentlichen dienst um rechtsextreme
netzwerke auf effektiv aufdecken zu
können brauchen die sicherheitsbehörden
aber moderne befugnisse es reicht nicht
dass ich das festnetz abhören darf oder
sms-nachrichten wenn ein solcher zustand
erreicht ist dann muss es mir auch
möglich sein westliche dienste mit
quellen tk und online-durchsuchungen
durchsuchen zu können und da ist es eben
nicht ausreichend wenn wir hier keine
modernen befugnisse haben
und bei der aufnahme der
kriegsflüchtlinge aus der ukraine
beharren sie
verglich verweigern sie hier die
übernahme der führungsverantwortung in
unserem land nach wie vor kommt täglich
bis zu 10.000 der frauen und kinder nach
deutschland seit wochen warnen polizei
und helfer vor pädophilen und
menschenhändlern die dieses chaos
ausnutzen und trotzdem es gibt zwar in
der zwischenzeit endlich mehr präsenz
der bundespolizei an den bahnhöfen aber
es gibt immer noch keine schutzzone und
keine geordnete aufnahme und das geht
einfach nicht
es gibt auch bis heute trotz ja
ihrerseits immer wieder vorgenommene
ankündigungen keine systematischen
registrierung bei der einreise so wie es
die polen machen und wir wissen eben
nicht genau wer in unser land kommt und
die verteilung in unserem land
funktioniert eben nicht reibungsfrei sie
muten hier den kommunen ganz massive
belastungen zu bei mir im wahlkreis ist
gestern ein bus mit flüchtlingen
angekommen die eigentlich nach
niedersachsen hätten fahren sollen die
waren zutiefst verunsichert sie waren
verängstigt und es war auch für die
helfer vor ort eine sehr schwierige
situation
vor drei tagen sind bei uns busse
überhaupt nicht angekommen obwohl die
helferinnen und helfer stundenlang
gewartet haben um dann kurz vor
mitternacht zu erfahren dass die busse
gar nicht erst abgefahren sind ich
bringe das bewusst als beispiel sie sind
in berlin nicht abgefahren es ist
wichtig dass wir dem ehrenamt danken
aber ich liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr geehrte frau ministerin
damit frustrieren wir dass er nahm
dieses chaos müssen sie sofort abstellen
wir müssen wissen wer kommt und die
kommunen vor ort müssen informiert sein
es braucht den nationalen krisenstabes
braucht auch den nationalen flüchtlings
gipfel und wenn sie schon nicht auf die
union hören damit verbesserungen
eintreten dann hören sie doch wenigstens
auf die kommunalen spitzenverbände die
das fordern auf die hilfsorganisation
wie die diakonie auf die lände und auf
ihren koalitionspartner denn die alle
wissen aus gutem grund warum sie diesen
gipfel fordern und das ist keine zeit
des abwartens das ist auch keine zeit
für befindlichkeiten einer ministerin
sondern es ist eine zeit des handelns
bitte handeln sie hier endlich
und wirklich große sorge bereitet mir
der umgang der ampel mit dem
bevölkerungsschutz am dienstag sagte
bundesfinanzminister lindner hier an
dieser stelle ich zitiere aus dem
protokoll fraglos ist der zivilschutz im
kern natürlich eine aufgabe der länder
nein liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
ist fraglos falsch gemäß artikel 73
nummer 1 des grundgesetzes ist der
zivilschutz ausschließlich aufgabe des
bundes und der bund unterstützt die
länder auch im katastrophenfall und
da muss ich mich wirklich wunder nach
zwei jahren corona nach der flut und
jetzt nach der wirklich erschreckenden
bedrohungen durch bedrohung durch
russland ist diese ahnungslosigkeit des
bundesfinanzministers in keinster weise
mehr nachvollziehbar
sie fordern zu recht dass die bundeswehr
mit 100 milliarden euro gestärkt wird
das ist gut das ist richtig und das ist
wichtig aber das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz ist mindestens auch
wichtig wenn nicht ebenso wichtig weil
es die zweite seite der medaille der
äußeren und inneren sicherheit darstellt
das bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz
wird mit mickrigen zehn millionen euro
im zweiten
entwurf jetzt zusätzlich gefördert das
bedeutet armin schuster der präsident
des bbk hat 135 millionen angekündigt
die braucht er noch um alles das was wir
auch in der letzten legislaturperiode
beschlossen haben umzusetzen er bekommt
zusätzlich zehn millionen das ist viel
zu wenig und reicht gerade einmal um
waren sms zu versenden
sie investieren keinen zusätzlichen euro
in syrien in die nina vanek in die
nationale reserve für trinkwasser
notstrom gesundheit und notunterkünfte
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das ist
fahrlässig und wir haben doch gesehen
was wir brauchen wir brauchen ein
resilienz deutschland wir haben hier im
vergangenen jahr in der letzten
legislaturperiode die neuausrichtung des
bbk mit seiner zentrale stellen funktion
beschlossen und wenn sie wollen dass
dieses amt das auch umsetzen kann dann
braucht es verdammt noch mal eine
bessere finanzielle grundausstattung und
schaden den bevölkerungsschutz
ich bitte sie dringend an der stelle
nachzubessern
dringend und ich will noch drei punkte
zum abschluss sagen wenn sie es ernst
meinen mit der zivilen verteidigung mit
der warnung mit der neuausrichtung des
bbk und seine zentralstellen funktion
dann brauchen wir für die nächsten zehn
jahre ein sonder volumen von mindestens
10 milliarden euro und deshalb bitte ich
sie alle nachdrücklich wir müssen an
dieser stelle nachbessern für ein
zivilschutz und einen besseren
bevölkerungsschutz in deutschland danke
schön
die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der unions fraktion
andrea in lindholz er war das
und das präsidium hat gewechselt
wolfgang kubicki hat hier die leitung
übernommen
[Musik]
also wird die kollegin ja media steht
für bündnis 90 die grünen das wort
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die herausforderung der innenpolitik in
den letzten jahren waren oft größer als
der politische wille sie wirklich
anzugehen sei es zum beispiel eine
lösungsorientierte migrationspolitik der
kampf gegen rechtsextremismus oder ein
wirksamer zivilschutz ist super dass die
da jetzt mehr tun wollen das hätten sie
natürlich auch schon in den letzten 16
jahren machen können
die neue regierung ist angetreten um das
zu ändern wir wollen ein vorbereiteter
und ein packender start sein und der
vorliegende haushalt des
innenministeriums zeigt das
selbstvertrauen und auch den politischen
willen zum anpacken schwarz auf weiß in
der migrationspolitik
haben wir die ideologische sackgasse der
letzten jahre endlich hinter uns
gelassen nämlich den trugschluss dass
die bekämpfung von migration politische
handlungsfähigkeit sei aber wer
suggeriert dass man in einer
krisengebeutelten welt migration einfach
so ausknipsen kann der wird stets an der
realität scheitern
um die herausforderung wirklich
anzupacken müssen der migration als
realität anerkennen und selbstbewusst
gestalten
die gesellschaft ist hier schon lange
weiter als die politik ist der letzten
jahre gewesen ist die zivilgesellschaft
war es doch die wir schaffen das
geschafft hat aber
darauf darf sich der staat jetzt
natürlich nicht aus und bund und länder
dürfen die kommunen und auch die
freiwilligen nicht im stich lassen neben
besseren strukturen für die erste
aufnahme und versorgung geht es jetzt
darum
allen bei uns ankommenden menschen mit
integrationskursen und
integrationsangeboten zur seite zu
stehen zu ihrer ausfinanzierung werden
der bis in den ergänzungs haushalt
hinein das notwendige tun
[Applaus]
damit unterbrechen weil ich gerne den
justizminister und frau kühn das bitten
würde ihre gespräche außerhalb des
plenarsaals fortzusetzen die hd
vielleicht hat sich schon beschwert zu
recht dass sie gestört wird und es auch
optisch nicht sehr klug
frau kollegin sie haben das wort
entschuldigung noch ein versäumnis
müssen wir korrigieren
während rechtsextreme gewalttaten immer
mehr geworden sind und die
radikalisierung
antidemokratischer gruppen zugenommen
hat haben die innenminister eine
vergangenheit oft weggesehen und
verharmlost aber diese verharmlosung hat
rechten netzwerken viel raum gegeben und
eine massive sicherheitslücke erzeugt
der nsu die anschläge in halle in hama
und auch der mord an walter lübke das
ist nur die spitze des eisbergs des
menschen verachten rechtsterrorismus in
deutschland aber ich kann ihnen sagen
die zeiten der bagatellisierung sind
vorbei
diese bundesregierung übernimmt
verantwortung und hat den kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus endlich zur zentralen
priorität deutscher innenpolitik gemacht
damit setzt die ministerin face die
richtigen schwerpunkte vielen dank dafür
es ist gut dass die experten und
expertinnen unserer behörden und vor
allem im bundesinnenministerium in
diesem bereich vermehrt und verstärkt
werden sollen die bundeszentrale für
politische bildung fördert die
medienkompetenz umfeld muss zu entlasten
und die gesellschaftliche resilienz zu
stärken durch den kreml gesteuerte des
informations und hasskampagnen im netz
sind zu einem fall beeinflussen faktor
im westen geworden deshalb ist jeder
euro der in projekte gegen
rechtsextremismus
gesteckt wird ein beitrag zur
internationalen widerstandsfähigkeit von
demokratien gerade im globalen system
wettbewerb und das müssen wir weiter
ausbauen
ich finde es sehr gut dass wir im
kontext von putins angriffskrieg jetzt
endlich über den zivilschutz sprechen
das ist längst überfällig
das zeigen auch schon der
fehlgeschlagene wahltag 2020 und die
flutkatastrophe im letzten sommer die
katastrophenhilfe und der zivilschutz
wurden in den letzten jahren wirklich
gefährlich vernachlässigt und das lag
auch ehrlich gesagt daran dass in der
union oft sicherheit beim militär
aufgehört hat und genau dieses verkürzte
sicherheitsverständnis ist ein
sicherheitsrisiko
und auch hier dürfen wir uns nicht auf
der arbeit der ehrenamtlichen ausruhen
denn die funktioniert genau dann am
besten wenn es eine professionelle
struktur gibt die ansprechbar ist und
die den überblick behält thw rotes kreuz
und die freiwillige feuerwehren haben
immer wieder großartiges geleistet aber
wir brauchen ein starkes bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
als zentrale koordinierungsstelle
ja und geeignete gerät und auch eine
angemessene personelle ausstattung
brauchen im haushalt eine entsprechende
finanzierung der haben jetzt viel schon
über die bundeswehr und deren stärken
gesprochen aber im notfall ist es eben
auch wichtig dass wir unsere
zivilbevölkerung im katastrophenfall
schützen und auch versorgen können also
setzen wir die seit einem jahr
vorliegende neuausrichtung des bundesamt
für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe jetzt endlich in die
realität rum ich komme zum schluss liebe
kollegen
wir dürfen keine angst vor den
innenpolitischen herausforderungen der
vergangenen jahre haben der vorliegende
haushalt gibt uns die mittel und den
rahmen an die hand um diese endlich
anzugehen nutzen wir sie vielen dank
amira hass schäfer war dass sie ist
mitglied im haushaltsausschuss und für
die grünen auch die berichterstatterin
für diesen etat nächster redner ist
markus mühle auch er setzt im
haushaltsausschuss ist mitglied der
fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren wenn man haushalt für
innenpolitik und heimat hört klingt das
erst mal sehr gut das hört sich nach
steuermitteln für den schutz unserer
heimat an und nach allen erforderlichen
maßnahmen zur sicherheit unserer bürger
die realität frau ministerin sieht
leider ganz anders aus angefangen beim
völlig unzureichend grenzschutz viel zu
wenigen neuen bundespolizisten
mangelhaften katastrophenschutz oder dem
geplanten absinken des gesamthaushaltes
um gleich bei den tragischen ereignissen
der letzten wochen zu bleiben die
bundespolizei muss an den grenzen genau
kontrollieren können wer ein echter
flüchtling ist oder ein trittbrettfahrer
das leid
das leid der flüchtenden ukraine darf
nicht als einfallstor einer
unkontrollierten einwanderung nach
deutschland missbraucht werden und jetzt
wo wir so viele frauen kinder und
familien zeitweise unterbringen müssen
endlich alle ausreisepflichtigen und
abgelehnten asylbewerber der vergangenen
jahre abgeschoben werden
frau ministerin während polen
vorbildlich flüchtlinge registriert
scheitert die deutsche regierungspolitik
schon wieder bei der konsequenten
bekämpfung illegaler migration es mutet
geradezu absurd an aber unter anderem
aus schlichtem mangel an fingerabdrücke
reden und der möglichkeit des abgleichs
unter den behörden bereits 2017 wurde
bekannt dass mehr als 90 prozent der
ausländerbehörden fingerabdrücke nicht
elektronisch abgleichen können ein
völlig unhaltbarer zustand
bleiben wir beim thema innere sicherheit
1000 zusätzliche stellen bei der
bundespolizei sind ein anfang aber
zuerst kommt die ausbildung und ersten
drei jahren dann die eigentliche
verstärkung und vor allem in den
kommenden jahren geht jährlich ein
beträchtlicher teil der beamten in den
ruhestand insofern ist die netto
verstärkung nicht groß sondern
kompensiert hauptsächlich die
altersbedingten abgänge erschreckend
kommt hinzu die mittelfristige
finanzplanung ein absinken nicht
erwähnte des bereits des haushalts für
das innenministerium bereits nächstes
jahr um 2,6 milliarden euro vorsieht von
den neuen polizisten die dieses jahr bei
der bundespolizei fertig ausgebildet
sind wir hatten viele in ballungszentren
mit hohen mieten versetzt bieten die
sich die jungen polizei absolventen oft
nicht leisten können und so
wohngemeinschaften bilden oder lange
strecken pendeln müssen hier besteht
dringender handlungsbedarf für eine
lösung und die lösung heißt nicht dass
die wohn fürsorge des bundes wohnungen
in den ballungsgebieten zu den gleichen
hohen mieten anbietet kommen wir zu ein
paar punkten bei der sachausstattung
unsere sicherheitskräfte die im letzten
jahr gestartete und von uns in der
letzten legislatur bereits intensive und
intensiv unterstützte auslieferungen des
neuen modularen körper schutzes begrüßen
wir ausdrücklich es bleibt zu hoffen
dass die flächendeckende ausstattung
zügig erfolgt die umsetzung der vom
parlament bereits im jahr 2019
beschlossen und flutung der transport
hubschrauber der bundespolizei schleppt
sich dahin eine vergabe des auftrags ist
nach fast dreijähriger dauer noch immer
nicht erfolgt dabei müssen die fast 40
jahre alten transporthubschrauber sehr
dringend ersetzt werden beim digital
ausbau hinten wir anderen ländern um
viele jahre hinterher viel zu oft
funktioniert hat digitalfunk bei
polizeilichen einsatzlagen nicht
störungsfrei bei den
bereitschaftspolizisten der länder sind
die ausrüstungen oft nicht kompatibel
und gleichwertig wodurch gemeinsame
einsatzlagen mit der bundespolizei ganz
erheblich erschwert werden es gibt viel
zu tun frau ministerin ich freue mich
auf die kommenden haushaltsverhandlungen
in denen wir uns mit unseren anträgen
für die innere sicherheit stark machen
werden um deutschland vom kopf zurück
auf die füße zu stellen ich danke für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr von der grünen
[Applaus]
nicht dass der kollege dr thorsten lieb
fdp-fraktionen
[Applaus]
willkommen zurück wir haben sie vermisst
schön sie wiederzusehen
sehr geehrte frau bundesgenossen ich
auch
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin feser
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen vor
wenigen tagen habe ich das
gemeindezentrum der jüdischen gemeinde
in frankfurt am main besucht direkt
neben dem gemeindezentrum befindet sich
eine grundschule auch eine kita ist dort
untergebracht ist ein deutliches zeichen
für die aktivität der gemeinde aber
jedes mal wenn man da vorbeigeht es ist
ausgesprochen erdrückend die
fortbestehende notwendigkeit von
sicherheitseinrichtungen
immer wieder stelle ich mir die frage
wie fühlt sich das an für die kinder und
jugendlichen jeden tag in einer solchen
situation in schule und kita zu kommen
dass dies leider weiter notwendig ist
zeigt eine aktuelle studie es ist
erschütternd zu lesen dass rund ein
drittel der jungen erwachsenen 30 jahre
in diesem land antisemitisch denken
trotz aller anstrengungen 75 jahre nach
dem ende des zweiten weltkrieges und dem
holocaust ist es nicht gelungen das
gespenst des antisemitismus aus diesem
land endgültig zu vertreiben deswegen
sage ich eines klar solange irgend eine
jüdische einrichtung oder institution in
diesem land noch diese art von sicherung
benötigt so lange muss uns klar sein
dass diese zentrale herausforderung bei
uns auf der tagesordnung bleibt deswegen
müssen wir alle gemeinsam mit aller
kraft tag für tag gegen antisemitismus
kämpfen haben
deshalb
deshalb bin ich die regierung und der
ministerin ausgesprochen dankbar dass
das nicht nur ein lippenbekenntnis ist
sondern diese notwendigkeit des handelns
klaren fußabdruck im etat zeigt nämlich
insbesondere durch die konkret
angekündigte ausfinanzierung der
umfassenden maßnahmen mittel für
prävention zb im umfang von mehr als
zehn millionen euro und ich freue mich
sehr darauf in der detaildiskussionen
gemeinsam dafür zu sorgen dass wir
effizient und zielgerichtet diese mittel
auf die straße wochen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
gerade gerade das bundesministerium des
innern zeichnet sich durch eine
besondere vielfalt der aufgaben aus
gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt und
heimat und netzpolitik verfassung
verwaltungsmodernisierung die liste
lässt sich ja fast unendlich verlängern
jedes dieser zentralen themen für unsere
gesellschaft wäre einer eigenen debatte
heute heute wahrscheinlich wert aber in
den kommenden wochen haben wir dazu
reichlich gelegenheit vor allem aber der
ukraine krieg und die offenen aufgaben
im bereich
katastrophen und bevölkerungsschutz
haben enorme auswirkungen jetzt schon
auf den aktuellen etat erste antworten
sind schon drin dafür dafür haben wir zu
danken aber bewusst muss es glaube ich
allen seien in diesem saal die die lage
ist dynamisch die lage wird sich
weiterentwickeln und natürlich können
wir stand heute noch nicht abschließend
etwas dazu sagen wohin uns die reise
führt und jeder der anderes formuliert
und glaubt und erwartete müssten heute
die abschließende aussage treffen der
hat die welt nicht verstanden der weiß
nicht wie die lage sich dynamisch
entwickelt
gerade die fülle der aufgaben und der
aktuellen herausforderung macht es aber
wichtig auch zu fokussieren ich werde
ein augenmerk zum beispiel darauf legen
die anzahl von programmen mit den
teilweise ähnlichen zustellungen sehr
genau auf den prüfstand zu stellen dass
wir die ziele erreichen und bei den
anstehenden und dringend notwendigen
digitalisierungs aufgaben sage ich mit
über zehn jahren anwaltliche erfahrung
in it projekten da müssen wir sehr genau
hingucken projekte neigen gerne dazu
länger zu dauern und teurer zu werden
was wir aber wollen als ampel ist mit
jedem eingesetzten euro in diesen
bereich das maximum an digitalisierung
und verwaltungsmodernisierung
herauszuholen über freundin freuen
daneben muss natürlich der fokus ist es
schon angesprochen auf den aktuellen
herausforderungen liegen viele dinge
kugel in richtung der union sind zu
lange liegen geblieben großen
ankündigungen auf pressekonferenzen ist
wenig bis gar nichts gefolgt 16 jahre
unions geführtes innenministerium haben
mehr offene baustellen und mehr fragen
hinterlassen als das aufgaben erledigt
worden sind es doch die wahrheit und sie
hätten im ersten regierungsentwurf auch
die chance gehabt nachzuarbeiten das ist
doch unterblieb wir packen das jetzt an
als ampel daher sind die zehn millionen
für das bbk genau richtig investiert
damit wir dort endlich ein sprung nach
vorne kommen es wird höchste zeit kein
wahltag mehr wie 2020 darf uns passieren
frau ministerin
das bundesministerium des inneren trifft
besondere verantwortung für den
zusammenhalt der gesellschaft und für
die sicherheit in unserem land dafür
haben sie meine haben sie unsere
unterstützung ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit herzlichen dank herr
kollege
thorsten liebte war das und während hier
die abgeordneten im bundestag
diskutieren findet ja in brüssel wir
haben es vorhin angesprochen und auch
gesehen das g7-treffen stadt das war bis
15.15 angekündigt danach sollte olaf
scholz ein statement abgeben sollte das
kommen dann werden wir dort live hin
schalten jetzt spricht hier im plenum
victor perli für die linksfraktion er
sitzt im haushaltsausschuss
vielen dank herr präsident meine damen
und herren durch den schlimmen krieg in
der ukraine sind millionen menschen auf
der flucht tausende kommen jeden tag
nach deutschland
wir erleben eine große welle der
solidarität aus der bevölkerung und in
den kommunen alle die sich hier einst
haben große anerkennung respekt verdient
herzlichen gang
dieser haushaltsentwurf wo sie dem
parlament eine woche später vorgelegt
wegen des kriegsausbruchs dafür habe ich
volles verständnis wir haben kein
verständnis dafür dass nicht ein
einziger zusätzlicher euro
hereingekommen ist um die kommunen zu
unterstützen die flüchtlinge jetzt gut
zu betreuen
städte und kommunen sind und gemeinden
müssen bei der unterbringung der
geflüchteten komplett in vorleistung
getreten dabei hat der bund eigentlich
eine rücklage die sogenannte flüchtlings
rücklage um menschen in not zu helfen
ich hab mit mehreren bürgermeistern in
meiner heimat gesprochen in salzgitter
und wolfenbüttel diesen unzufrieden sie
mieten wohnungen an sie sorge für
integration sie stellen personal ein
aber sie wissen nicht was sie bekommen
nicht vom bund nicht vom land frau
ministerin warum haben sie nicht eine
soforthilfe bereitgestellt mit diesem
haushaltsentwurf um zu zeigen wir gehen
hier schnell voran wir möchten dass sie
die mitmachen
komplett auf derzeit gefällt ist dass
diesen haushalt sind nur kürzungen bei
der integration vorgesehen sind zum
beispiel bei den integrationskursen das
muss zurückgenommen werden sie haben es
angedeutet dass das in diese richtung
geht das finden wir richtig es muss
erhöht werden genauso bei der
migrationsberatung der bekommen briefe
von den wohlfahrtsverbänden die sagen
wir brauchen jetzt dringend mehr
unterstützung brauchen
planungssicherheit und wir finger als
linker die müssen sie auch bekommen mit
blick auf den krieg stellen sich jetzt
viele bürger fragen
wie sind wir eigentlich geschützt in
einer guten situation im ernstfall wie
ist der katastrophenschutz in meiner
region aufgestellt auch die korona
pandemie und die hochwasserkatastrophe
letzten jahr haben gezeigt dass es viel
verbesserungsbedarf gibt es
war zum beispiel ein großer fehler das
ist natürlich auch ein ausdruck der
kaputt sparpolitik in diesem juli bereit
ist muss dass man vielerorts die sirenen
abgebaut hat was für ein wahnsinn dass
man jetzt wieder aufstellen muss das war
völlig falsch und wir haben wir haben
auch keine übersicht darüber wo es
welche mittel gibt es muss dringend
behoben werden sagt seehofer oft
angekündigt und es ist nicht passiert
ist darf nicht mehr vernachlässigt
werden wir brauchen ein update beim
bevölkerungs und katastrophenschutz
meine damen und herren es ist
erschreckend dass inzwischen 600
neonazis per haftbefehl gesucht werden
die nsu mordserien der terroranschlag
eines nazis in hanau mannes darf nicht
weggeschaut werden hier muss konsequent
entwaffnet werden frau ministerin sie
haben einen sehr ambitionierten plan
vorgelegt wie sie gegen nazis strukturen
gegen rassismus gegen völkische
ideologie vorgehen möchten das begrüßen
wir ausdrücklich und wie werden sie
dabei unterstützen auch mit eigenen
vorschlägen ich hoffe dass wir das
beraten werden auch den
haushaltsberatungen und freue mich auf
eine gute und geschlossene handlung der
klare kante gegen rechts vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege tallinn
[Applaus]
als nächsten gegner hören wir den
kollegen martin gerster spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident werte
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
ministerin nancy faeser ja es hat
wirklich lange gedauert aber jetzt steht
tatsächlich zum allerersten mal in der
geschichte unseres landes eine frau an
der spitze des bundesinnenministeriums
und zum ersten mal seit 16 jahren ist
die spd wieder direkt verantwortlich für
die innenpolitik des bundes und endlich
endlich ist es möglich zusammen mit den
grünen und auch mit der fdp so manche
innenpolitische weiche neu auszurichten
neu zu stellen viel zeit zur
einarbeitung die sonst übliche 100 tage
schonfrist gab und gibt es aber für die
neue ministerin nancy faeser und ihr
team nicht putins angriffskrieg bringt
viel leid für millionen menschen viele
tote verwundete und geflüchtete krieg
mitten in europa ich hätte mir das wie
so viele andere menschen überhaupt nicht
vorstellen können und daher machen sich
viele menschen auch große sorgen um die
sicherheit in europa und auch für die
innenpolitik in deutschland gibt es
immense herausforderung eine davon
einige davon waren bereits vor
kriegsbeginn in der ukraine offenkundig
andere sind ganz neu hinzugekommen
orientierung klare haltung
handlungsstärke das ist jetzt gefragt
wenn sicherheit im wandel das gebot der
stunde ist und was sich jetzt schon
sagen lässt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen unsere bundesinnenministerium
nancy faeser ist ein gewinn für unser
land und die bundesregierung vom ersten
tag an hat sie sich vor ort einen
eindruck von den vielfältigen aufgaben
verschafft und zahlreiche gespräche
geführt bei der bundespolizei beim
technischen hilfswerk aber auch mit
ihren kollegen kollegen in den ländern
und in den eu-mitgliedsstaaten sie ist
präsent sie stellt sich den medien und
der öffentlichkeit sie erklärt ihre
politik und welche schritte jetzt
notwendig sind das war nicht immer so
aber das ist jetzt gerade in diesen
zeiten ganz besonders wichtig und es tut
gut daran daran weiter zu arbeiten ich
glaube wir sind ja auch dem sehr sehr
guten weg liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die ampel regierung die spd an der
spitze des bundesinnenministeriums dazu
noch eine frau böse gerüchte wurden in
die welt gesetzt dass jetzt im haushalt
des bundesinnenministeriums
übels gekürzt werden würde der
überarbeitete
regierungsentwurf liegt nun vor und
siehe da das gesamtvolumen des einzel
plans liegt bei 15 milliarden euro das
ist wenn man den baubereich raus rechnet
neuer rekord ein zuwachs von 844
millionen euro außerdem sieht der
entwurf
1660 zusätzliche stellen vor ich finde
ein sehr gutes verhandlungsergebnis das
uns hier vorgelegt wurde für die
weiteren haushaltsberatungen
vor allem die bundespolizei profitiert
vom stellen aufwuchs das ist wie ich
finde enorm wichtig unsere
bundespolizisten und bundespolizisten
leisten seit jahren nahezu unglaubliches
in einsätzen verschiedenster art ich
denke da vor allem aber nicht nur an die
einsätze in zusammenhang mit den
demonstrationen und so genannten
spaziergängen gegen die korona politik
zu recht stehen rund 1000 zusätzliche
stellen für die bundespolizei im
haushaltsentwurf das ist eine klare
botschaft wie ich finde wertschätzung
und entlastung für unsere polizeikräfte
die für uns rechtsstaat und demokratie
verteidigen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
was für uns als spd fraktion aber auch
für mich persönlich und ich habe es
jetzt auch in den redebeiträgen von
janina schäfer und im kollegen thorsten
lieb gehört was uns hier freut ist dass
wir in diesem regierungsentwurf auch
eine neue schwerpunktsetzung vorfinden
die bekämpfung von rechtsextremismus
ist jetzt sache der chefin
das zeigt sich in dem neuen aktionsplan
den die innenministerin vor wenigen
tagen persönlich vorgestellt hat und
auch im haushaltsentwurf die
bundesregierung hatte ja im letzten jahr
schon ein paket auf den weg gebracht um
entschieden gegen rechte gewalt gegen
rassismus gegen hetze und hass im netz
und auf der straße vorgehen zu können
die wehrhafte demokratie braucht aber
aus meiner sicht nicht nur beschlüsse
sie braucht auch mittel und die sind
jetzt in diesem haushaltsentwurf endlich
sichtbar und das ist auch gut so liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen den
bevölkerungs und katastrophenschutz aber
auch dem zivilschutz in der
zivilverteidigung kommt immer größere
bedeutung zu starkregen stromausfälle
und einige andere szenarien erfordern
eine größere aufmerksamkeit das ist
vollkommen richtig beim thw beim bbk
sieht der regierungsentwurf mehr mittel
und auch mehr personal vor sehr gut aber
die frage ist in der tat für die
anstehenden haushaltsberatungen
ob wir nicht noch mehr tun müssen um den
neuen herausforderungen gerecht zu
werden zum glück können wir auch viele
ehrenamtliche und hauptamtliche
einsatzkräfte bauen die immer zur stelle
sind wenn andere hilfe brauchen dafür an
dieser stelle ein dankeschön und zwar
wirklich von herzen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
dieser regierungsentwurf ist bekanntlich
vor dem angriff putins auf die ukraine
erarbeitet worden cyber angriffe und des
informationskampagnen der zivilschutz
neue aufgaben um unsere bevölkerung zu
schützen erfordert bei unseren
haushaltsberatung eine neue
prioritätensetzung das haben schon
einige vor mir angesprochen vor allem
aber denke ich für die große zahl an
geflüchteten aus der ukraine brauchen
wir schutz unterstützung und integration
deshalb gilt es jetzt zügig deutschkurse
und kinderbetreuung zu organisieren und
berufsabschlüsse schneller anzuerkennen
und ich finde auch der sport kann
menschen unkompliziert zusammen zu
bringen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren sehr geehrter herr präsident ich
sehe schon sie wollen wir ins wort
fallen letzter satz sicherheit im wandel
bedeutet dass wir unsere demokratie und
unseren rechtsstaat verteidigen gegen
extremisten dass wir diejenigen
wertschätze unterstützen die sich
hauptamtlich und ehrenamtlich jeden tag
aufs neue für unsere sicherheit
einsetzen und dass wir denjenigen schutz
und zuhause bieten die jetzt vor krieg
und zerstörung fliehen mussten und
müssen herzlichen dank
martin gerster war das und sie sehen
unschön mittlerweile ein signal aus
brüssel wo wir olaf scholz bundeskanzler
erwarten nach dem treffen mit den g 7
staaten und auch nach dem datum geben
wollte er sich hier in kürze
im bundestag spricht nun mechthilde
wittmann es ist ihre erste rede diese
halten wurzel ist mitglied der
herr präsident frau bundesministerin
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir heute
über den haushalt des innenministeriums
reden dann reden wir über eigentlich
einen der relevantesten haushalte wir
hier zu besprechen haben denn wir reden
darüber dass die sicherheit in unserem
land gewährleistet wird für unsere
bürgerinnen und bürger und gerade auch
für diejenigen die jetzt in die
sicherheitszone zu uns flüchten und
deswegen sollten wir diesen haus war
ganz besonders ernst nehmen und
ich freue mich frau bundesministerin
dass der haushalt eine hohe kontinuität
aufweist zu den haushalten die in den
letzten jahren aufgewachsen sind die
frau kolleginnen holz ja bereits
mitgeteilt hat und ausgeführt hat sie
weisen auf steigerungen im
personalbereich genauso wie in den
ausgaben die wir auf die verschiedenen
politikfelder legen und damit machen sie
eigentlich ein kompliment an die
vorgängerregierungen die damit nämlich
genau das auf gewissen haben worauf sie
aufbauen können sie haben ein
wohlbestelltes haus vorgefunden und wir
sind an ihrer seite wenn sie es in
gleicher art und weise weiter vor
und entgegen dem gelächter dass sich in
der mitte des hauses mal wieder auf tod
kann dieses alles auch mit zahlen und
belegt werden die kriminalitätsstatistik
sagt uns ganz eindeutig dass sie nahezu
jedem straftatbestand die zahlen
kontinuierlich nach unten gehen daran
wollen wir gemeinsam weiterarbeiten und
wir wollen uns eine sache noch einmal
besonders an dem nämlich die hose
steigen die straftaten steigen dort wo
digitale bezug da ist und sie steigen
überall dort wo sexuelle motivation im
haus im raum steht insbesondere bei
kindern und da sollten wir keine
gelegenheit auslassen es gemeinsam
anzupacken regel 40
irene und bringen lassen sie uns aber
auch auf den aktuell brennendsten punkt
den wir haben ein gehen die frage der
migration und vor allen dingen die frage
der flug zu können hier bei uns denn das
ist nicht die migration die wir aus
20.15 können das ist eine notsituation
in der wir gehalten sind allen allen zu
helfen die jetzt kommen und zunächst
auch schlicht nur deswegen weil sie in
not geraten sind und unabhängig davon
wie ihr ursprünglicher status war und
dafür glaube ich haben wir am anfang die
lage unterschätzt und von ministerin da
hört man leider auch mit der einigkeit
da haben auch sie die lage unterschätzt
ich denke an unsere sondersitzung im
innenausschuss am neunten dritten als
sie noch davon sprachen dass es eine
registrierung so gar nicht nötig wäre
und dass der königsteiner schlüssel
nicht benötigt würde weil die länder
würden ja auf zuruf sagen sie hätten
noch kapazitäten ja klar was mache ich
denn wenn akut geflohen wird natürlich
sage ich da krieg ich noch nicht vorne
her und das schaffen wir schon im
übrigen schaffen müsste ehrenamtlichen
und es schaffen es will ich einmal hier
erwähnt haben die vielen schon seit
monaten überlasteten angestellten und
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
kommunen
dort wird es geschafft
und sie haben nach gesteuerten nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am 17
seither wird ja faktisch der
königsteiner schlüssel angewendet er hat
im moment das mittel der wahl ist
gleichwohl man das sicher auch noch
einmal nachjustieren könnte und dabei
hätten wir das ganze so einfach haben
können es beginnt mitte zusammenarbeit
mit polen an den außengrenzen der
anderer staaten zur ukraine dort kommen
die menschen an und werden systematisch
registriert was hindert uns daran dort
mit den grenzbehörden zusammenzuarbeiten
digitale schnittstellen zu schaffen und
verbindungsbeamte zu schaffen sowie das
anders 30 deutschen grenze im rahmen der
haushoch getan haben bis heute ist
natürlich
nichts 60 busse und bahnen habe die
eingestellt sind sondern sich auch
kollegen in holz wissen wann fahren sie
ab wo fahren sie hin man kompensieren
das wissen die vor ort nämlich so und so
oft gar nicht um eine land heute
erzählen mir dass schwierige sachen und
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass wir immer
noch nicht wirklich für registrieren das
tun wir nämlich nicht sondern wir
greifen auf das ungeliebte mittel der
schleierfahndung in wirklichkeit zurück
die bundespolizei geht in die züge und
versucht aufzunehmen wir erwischen aber
nicht die die natürlich beginnen dieses
mittel auch ein stück für sich
auszunutzen und die wollen wir aber als
erste erwischen
und die möchte noch ein weiteres ganz
kurz anmelden sie haben in einem
interview gesagt es würde vor ort hat
man bei den ausländerbehörden das kann
ich so nicht stehen lassen ich möchte
nochmals sagen ich bedanke mich bei den
kommunen und den ehrenamtlichen sie aber
in perfect haben in hand von grund nach
unten zur landung von monika nicht das
nicht fest
und lassen sie mich ein letztes
anstrengen die frage des extremismus
vollkommen zu recht sagen sie dass sie
dies mit großem mitteln unterlegt haben
wir sind dann mir das leid und das haben
alle regen in den letzten jahren auch
für die vorhergehende bundesregierung
jeweils getan aber sind sie bitte nicht
blind und ich habe das heute mit freude
gehört bei der frage des
linksextremismus und auch des
islamistischen und da muss ich einfach
noch ein wort sagen
linksextremismus richtet sich fast immer
gegen unsere polizeibeamten und das gilt
es zu schützen diese gilt es zu schützen
und zwar insbesondere auch voraussagen
einer bundesministerin dies als form des
zivilen ungehorsam als legitim
betrachtet da sind sie nicht bei ihnen
und ich danke ihnen
vielen dank frau
will hier widmen
größte rednerin ist die kollegin lamya
kaddor
mir kader sprechen für inneres und
heimat für ihre fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen essen szenen
die ich nicht vergessen werde und ich
möchte diese gänge hier mit ihm tagen
hauptbahnhof berlin freitagnachmittag
ende einer sitzungswoche vor mir eine
junge frau mit einem säugling im wagen
sie kann die abteile nicht finden
mehrere taschen hängen an ihr sie
beginnt zu schwitzen die reihe die
reihung der waggons hat sich verändert
die db hat das auch schon durch gesagt
aber wie soll sie das verstehen ihr
ticket nun das abteil wollen einfach
nicht zusammenpassen die säuglings
schreit und sie kann einfach nicht mehr
zumindest denke ich dass ich werde
sicherlich ein stein vom herzen als ich
sie auf englisch frage ob hier helfen
kann
sie muss ein paar abteile weiter sie
welche mit mich an und geht man vom band
was denke ich bei mir
wenn ich das wäre mir meinen kindern an
der hand in einem fremden land in einem
fremden zug ein paar habseligkeiten dich
retten konnte zusammengerafft in einer
tasche mein mann zu hause geblieben um
deutschland zu verteidigen in welches
land wirklich überhaupt gehen wer würde
mir helfen
systemwechsel zu hause angekommen in
duisburg mein nachbar frührentner ist
ehrenamtlich beim thw aktiv er möchte
nach polen fahren um dort direkt zu
helfen seine frau wir ihnen auf keinen
fall fahren lassen sie hat angst um ihn
meine damen und herren sie hat angst
wenn man nach polen will europa wir
sprechen hier von europa wir erleben
gerade tektonische verschiebungen in
sicherheit also die sicherheit in der
wir uns zu sehr wähnten ist ein
zerbrechliches gut ich bin den
ehrenamtlichen ehrenamtlichen helfern
und helfen so dankbar für die
selbstverständlichkeit mit der sie
helfen die polizistinnen und polizisten
den thw mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern
auch mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern von
städten und gemeinden
wir stimmen gerade als land
und als eine menge und ich bin das
möchte ich einmal deutlich sagen
beeindruckt von meinem land und ja
dankbar dass wir das hinkriegen auch
sehr dankbar datenblock dass wir für die
aufnahme von kriegsflüchtlingen eine
europäische einigung herbeigeführt haben
so geht europa es ist unser europa und
gut möglich dass dieses europa den kreml
überrascht hat und wenn dem so ist dann
ist es gut
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und doch der
russische angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine stellt uns nicht nur
international ganz anders als in den
letzten jahrzehnten vor immense
herausforderungen was heißt das
eigentlich für eine vorausschauende
innenpolitik wir brauchen eine nationale
sicherheitsstrategie die an erweiterten
sicherheitsbegriff zur grundlage hat und
ich bin dem bundeskanzler sehr dankbar
dass er gestern hier im hohen haus von
verteidigung und sicherheit sprach wir
können und dürfen militärische
verteidigung nicht ohne den zivilen
krisenschutz für die menschen in unserem
land denkt
die vergangen tage haben auch gezeigt in
der ukraine handelt es sich nicht nur um
alle militärischen krieg sondern auch
man im informationskrieg der im
digitalen raum ausgefochten wird gegen
hybride angriffe sollten wir gewappnet
sein möglicher beeinträchtigungen der
kritischen infrastruktur auch durch
cyber-angriffe müssen ernst genommen
werden dazu gehören ein möglicher
ausfall der strom und wasser oder
wärmeversorgung wärmeversorgung wir
wollen eine strategische neuausrichtung
zügige umsetzung der konzeption zivile
verteidigung stellen wir uns nur an
stromausfall in einer großstadt wie
hamburg und an meinem wahlkreis duisburg
vor nur drei tage ohne strom würden uns
lahmlegen und chaos erzeugen wir müssen
schnell reagieren können wir müssen
handeln bevor so etwas passiert nicht
wenn so etwas passiert
wie geht es aber auch nicht um
panikmache aber kluge politik handelt
vorausschauend deshalb gehen wir mit
klaren blick geben mit klaren blick
unsere neuen aufgaben an es ist daher
genau richtig dass sie frau
bundesinnenministerium feser bereits
angekündigt haben den zivilschutz
auszubauen jetzt gilt ist das bundesamt
für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik unabhängiger zu
stellen das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenschutz braucht eine massive
personelle und materielle stärkung das
bbk muss eine zentrale stelle sein um
sich an veränderte lagen schnell
anpassen zu können auch das thw steht
bereit seine aufgaben umfassen zu
erfüllen und wo nötig anzupassen zum
beispiel über die lebensmittel
bevorratung die zentral organisiert
gehört die resilienz fähigkeit ist für
unsere hoch technologisierten
gesellschaft einfach zentral und zwar
nicht nur beim zivilschutz es ist ein
trauerspiel wie die behörden die im
ernstfall genuine schutzpflichten des
staates umsetzen müssen in die
vergangenen jahre vom zuständigen csu
geführten haus klein gehalten und
personell abgekämpft wurden wie konnte
das geschehen möchte dieser stelle herrn
seehofer fragen aber dass das jetzt
wieder raus ich brauche nichts bringt
geschätzte kolleginnen und kollegen die
russische invasion der ukraine haben
auch durch desinformation und zwei watt
einer ernsten eine bedrohungslage
geschaffen aber hybride angriffe sind
nicht erst ein problem
sind nicht erst ein problem seit beginn
des blutigen krieges
sofort herr präsident aber eines ist
aber auch klar demokratie feinde mit
zugang zu informationen waffen und
munition extremisten jeglicher art
bücher nicht diener dieses staates sei
auch jeder einzelfall ist einer zu viel
und das werden wir nicht dulden und wo
nötig auch das dienstrecht anpassen
und der nächste regen kommt aus der fdp
fraktion
christian wirth ist das mitglied im
innenausschuss
[Applaus]
herr präsident werde kollegen der große
wurf ist eine ampelkoalition mit dem
einzelplan und 6 des innenministeriums
erwartungsgemäß nicht gelungen die
drängendsten probleme unseres landes
möchte auch die neue bundesregierung
nicht anpacken der kriegen der ukraine
seine folgen zeigen uns in vielen
bereichen die fehlentwicklung der
deutschen innenpolitik auf und in kaum
einem so deutlichen maße wie in der
asyl- und migrationspolitik seit der
merkelschen grenzöffnung haben sich
hunderttausende ausreisepflichtige in
deutschland festgesetzt fährt wertvolle
kapazitäten die wir nun dringend für
tatsächlich hilfsbedürftige ukrainische
frauen kinder und greise gebrauchen
könnten hier bedürfe es dringend einer
nationalen kraftanstrengung und
geltendes recht endlich umzusetzen
im bereich des grenzschutzes und der
bundespolizei offenbart sich ebenfalls
aufstockung bedarf nach einschätzung des
vorsitzenden der
bundespolizeigewerkschaft heiko teggatz
würden höchstens 60 prozent der über
polen einreißen und flüchtlinge
kontrolliert eine chance die von vielen
drittstaatsangehörigen genutzt wird um
unerkannt unter den ukrainischen
flüchtlingen her einzureisen um die
innere sicherheit ist es ebenfalls
schlecht bestellt ministerin feser wirft
die augenmerk offenbar nur auf
vermeintlichen rechtsextremismus auf dem
linken auge ist sie völlig blind
islamischer terrorismus scheint nur
nebensache zu sein was wir dringend
bräuchten ist ein paradigmenwechsel der
deutschen politik stärkung der inneren
sicherheit durch aufstockung der polizei
und sicherheitsbehörden
konsequente abschiebung ausreicht so
wichtiger und effektive grenzkontrollen
ein waschechter skandal ist es dass die
basilius erasmus stiftung nicht bei den
global zuschüssen zur
gesellschaftspolitischen und
demokratischen bildungsarbeit bedacht
wurde es verstößt nicht nur gegen
höchstrichterliche rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zur
gleichstellung
politischer strömungen 286 sondern auch
gegen die jahrzehntelang geübte praxis
des deutschen bundestages sie schaden
damit nicht nur wie von ihnen
beabsichtigt daher steht sondern der
demokratie in unserem lande insgesamt es
ist ein schlag ins
millionen wähler und zeigt dass ihnen
selbst offenkundig rechtswidrige
verhalten zur sicherung der eigenen
macht legitim zu sein scheint man sollte
sich schämen für sie zum schluss möchte
ich noch anhalten mann bitten einen
blick nur auf den einzelplan und 6 zu
werfen neuerdings wird er die ansicht
die volkszugehörigkeit sei nicht
identisch mit der staatsangehörigkeit
als verfassungsfeindlich eingestuft da
stolze stolzen durchgehört nicht
zwingend deutsche volkszugehörigkeit
sein musst sieht man schon an der
finanziellen förderung
deutscher staatsbürger sorbischer
volkszugehörigkeit ebenfalls fördert das
bmwi ausländische staatsbürger deutscher
volkszugehörigkeit
insbesondere in osteuropa
dies begrüßen wir selbstverständlich
ausdrücklich diese norm zu verdeutlichen
mit welt absurd
argumentationslinien die alternative für
deutschland in die vermeintliche
verfassungsfeindlichkeit gerückt werden
soll erhalten banken zur ebenfalls
empfohlen häufiger auf die zahlen des im
geschäftsbereich des bmi angeklickt und
den statistischen bundesamtes zu
vertrauen neuerdings arbeitet arbeitet
er allen ernstes mit zahlen der durch
annette karl hahne geführte amadeu
antonio stiftung ein sammelbecken
ehemaligen sed spitze und kommunisten
fleisch ist das ist der preis damit ein
christdemokrat auch unter der ampel
regierung weiterhin das bundesamt
befassung fassung schutz führen darf wer
weiß die bundeshaushalt lehnen wir ab
vielen dank und glückauf
vielen dank herr kollege patrick
auf christian wird von
manuel höferlin er ist der
innenpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident steckte
kolleginnen kollegen dieser haushalt des
innenministeriums zeigt vor allem eins
das zeigt einen paradigmenwechsel der
fortschritts koalition in der
innenpolitik sowohl sachlich aber vor
allen dingen auch im stil meine damen
und herren im stil bedeutet das nämlich
dass dieser haushalt geprägt ist davon
dass nicht parteitaktisches aufrechnen
sondern im kern zusammenarbeit in der
sache stattfindet und dieser fortschritt
koalition möchte gemeinsam etwas für die
menschen und das land bewegen und das
ist gut so und das führt meine damen und
herren am ende eben nicht auf ein stück
werk sondern auf ein gesamtwerk und ich
könnte jetzt leicht machen und mal breit
ausführen warum der fortschritt zu
dringend gebraucht wird was in den
letzten 16 jahren unter der union in
diesem innenpolitik falsch gemacht wurde
oder was gar nicht gemacht wurde aber
erstens liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wissen sie selbst das in die in der
innenpolitik in den letzten 16 jahren
unter ihnen das nicht immer eine
sternstunde war vor allen dingen mit
falschen prioritätensetzung und zweitens
möchte ich doch lieber nach vorne
schauen auf das was wir machen können
was unser land voranbringt und was auch
dem fortschritt für die bürgerinnen und
bürger wirken kann und dafür müssen wir
lediglich mal schauen in welchen feldern
die fortschritts koalition mehr tut als
das bisher der fall war sehen wir zum
beispiel die mittel beim
bevölkerungsschutz ich sags mal so der
wahltag war im besten fall eine warnung
für uns die schreckliche katastrophe
im aartal und die auswirkungen waren
auch die folgen davon waren versäumnisse
die getan einfach unterlassen wurden in
den letzten jahren im zivil- und
bevölkerungsschutz und der
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff russlands
auf die ukraine zeigt auch deutlich dass
wir darüber darüber hinausgehend auch
noch den abbau des zivilschutz der
letzten jahre vorangetrieben wurde und
das muss sich dringend ändern und damit
gehen wir auch in diesem haushalt an
und zwar mit hochdruck
wenn ich so höre sagte vorgänger das
alles zu wenig geld der entscheidende
punkt ist gerade beim bevölkerungsschutz
und beim zivilschutz nun ganz klar sagen
wir können nicht einfach nur geld darauf
schütten so wie sie das im weil probleme
in den letzten jahren immer getan haben
es uns löst sich von alleine sondern
gerade beim bevölkerungsschutz und beim
zivilschutz ist das problem dass die
strukturen nicht richtig gestimmt haben
das nicht klar war wer kennt wen anruft
das die organisation nicht ordentlich
war und ich habe das sehr interessiert
gehört frau den holz sie haben letztlich
ja zugesagt dass eine zentralstellen
funktion des bbk notwendig sei und ich
freue mich auf ihre unterstützung auch
die vorteile stützung der länder die
unter ihnen geführt sind wenn wir salz
wäre dafür eine grundgesetzänderung
brauchen damit danke ich für die zusage
von ihnen der union herzlichen dank
dafür
beispiel drei minuten hat will ich sagen
bevor der präsident nicht dazu ermahnt
das natürlich auch andere bereiche wie
zum beispiel die transformation in der
digitalisierung dazu führen dass wir den
cyber raum die cybersicherheit
voranbringen müssen wir müssen die
gesellschaftspolitik so ausrichten dass
wir extremismus jeder art dort auch von
allen akteuren bekämpft werden eine
starke prävention vorangetrieben wird
ich bin überzeugt dass dieser haushalt
fortschritt bedeutet und die
fortschritts koalition würden gemeinsam
nach vorne bringen herzlichen dank
vielen dank an alle die hilfe liegen
14,96 milliarden euro so steht es im
entwurf der bundesregierung soll das
bundesinnenministerium bekommen das sind
19 prozent weniger als im jahr 20 21
denn auch der bereich bauwesen ist nicht
mehr teil des innenministeriums dafür
wurde er ein eigenes gegründet martina
renner sprach jetzt für die
linksfraktionen mit der haben seite an
der entwurf des haushaltes setzt ein
positives signal keine gelder für die
extrem rechte des delius erwachsenes
stiftung
rechte lieben das licht aus staatlichen
mitteln finanziert werden das muss auch
in zukunft so bleiben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
rechtsextreme netzwerke zerschlagen
neonazis entwaffnen finanzströme rechte
akteure ausdrucken das sind die
forderungen die die linke ist seit
jahren vertritt mit der vorstellung des
aktionsplans gegen rechtsextremismus in
diese forderung jetzt im
bundesministerium angekommen wir finden
das gut
aber gerade weil wir diese punkte seit
jahren fordern wissen wir auch dass
absichtserklärung alleine nicht reichen
es braucht den willen diesen aktionsplan
auch durchzusetzen
und das kann nur gelingen wenn die
sicherheitsbehörden des bundes hiermit
ziehen mehr geld mehr geld wird alleine
nicht automatisch zu besseren
ergebnissen führen wir fordern erstens
das geld zielgerichtet so einzusetzen
damit das bundeskriminalamt in die lage
versetzt wird rechtsextreme netzwerke
effektiv zu bekämpfen
das selbst vor allem eine bessere
fachspezifische ausbildung also im
ergebnis besser geschultes personal
voraus ich möchte ein bka das mit
energie die einfach ermittler regel
verfolgt folge den waffen folge dem geld
wir fordern zweitens in zukunft keine
weiteren mittel aufwüchse für den
inlandsgeheimdienst
der inlandsgeheimdienst war noch nie ein
verbündeter beim kampf gegen
rechtsextreme netzwerke sondern hat
diese aktiv verhindert hat diesen aktiv
verhindert diesen kampf und neonazis vor
strafverfolgung geschützt es geht das
ist realität schon mal die berichte der
untersuchungsausschüsse da können sie
das alles nachlesen und es geht beim bv
nicht um mehr geld ich wünsche mir eine
aufklärung darüber wie das ideologische
und organisatorische wirken von hans
georg maßen vielleicht heute noch die
arbeit des amtes bestimmt da braucht es
dringend
katarische die öffentliche aufklärung
kommen sie wieder los
freundlicherweise zum schluss kommen
sie haben jetzt noch einen satz und da
muss ich
jetzt auch die drei sätzen von spd und
grünen
frau kollegin sind bereits 50 sekunden
über ihrer rede zurück sie haben einen
letzten satz vor gedacht
ich hoffe dass sie
gemeinsam mit uns
nicht nur den aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus in die tat umsetzen
sondern auch bei dem versprechen kleiden
wie sie es im koalitionsvertrag
formuliert haben dass es keine mittel
für staatliche hacking tools gibt auch
das werden wir in zukunft sehr genau
verfolgen als opposition vielen dank
martina renner
war das sprechen für antifaschismus auch
für innenpolitik und wir warten
weiterhin auf das statement von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz das war um
viertel nach drei angekündigt allerdings
wurde uns gesagt dass er noch mit den
staats und regierungschefs der g 7
staaten zusammen sitzt da besteht also
mehr redebedarf als ursprünglich geplant
in der debatte geht es jetzt weiter mit
sebastian hartmann sprecher für inneres
der sozialdemokrat
ich muss auch augsburg
aber ich wollte nur sagen die jetzt auch
so klatschen nicht auch für sie gilt das
abnehmen der maske zunächst mit einem
ordnungsruf bedacht wird dann beim
wiederholungsfall mit einem ordnungsgeld
das geht aus brienz vermittelt er meine
eigene fraktion nicht dass sie denken
ich habe nur so ein blick nach rechts
ich gucke auch nach links so
wobei meine fraktion nicht links sitzt
und über zu sagen nächster redner ist
der von mir sehr geschätzte kollege
sebastian hartmann spd fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren die der
regierungsentwurf liegt vor und
sicherheit ist das zentrale versprechen
eines modernen staates und darüber
werden wir in den nächsten wochen ringen
debattieren wenn es darum geht den guten
haushaltsentwurf dass unser haushalt
martin gerster auf den punkt gebracht
hat noch besser zu machen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen werden ja auch
einiges an vorschlägen schon vernommen
das wichtigste eine anfahrt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen diese
sicherheit steht im wandel wir sind mit
anderen herausforderungen konfrontiert
wenn wir die cyber lage betrachten wenn
wir die digitalen bedrohungslagen
unseres staates unserer gesellschaft
betrachten aber seit mehr als vier
wochen sind wir mit einer situation
konfrontiert die wir nicht geringer als
die größte humanitäre katastrophe auf
diesem europäischen kontinent seit ende
des zweiten weltkrieges betroffen und
wenn ich jetzt in richtung der cdu/csu
schau dann erlebe ich hier einiges an
vorwürfen in den raum gestellt worden
ist das will ich in aller deutlichkeit
sagen die nicht den hauch das chance des
beweises haben dass sie der realität
entsprechen und sie sollten sich fragen
ob sie angesichts dieser situation ihrer
rolle als konstruktive opposition
überhaupt gerecht werden wenn sie hier
mit falschparkern aber
ich kann ich kann ihnen versichern das
was ich hier machen ist eine trauma
aufarbeitung ihrer missglückten amtszeit
de maizière und horst seehofer wenn es
darum geht dass auf der einen seite von
angela merkel gesagt wird wir schaffen
das und der bayerische ministerpräsident
wenige wochen danach ruft es ist die
herrschaft des unrechts
frau kollegin ich sie und sie lassen der
kollege hat man offensichtlich
zwischenfrage auch zu dann bitte schön
präsidentin der hatte mich nicht ge sind
das vielfache winken vielen dank dass
sie die frage zu lassen weil sie das so
begonnen haben normalerweise beginnen
der im ausschuss immer damit die
opposition also uns zu beschimpfen jetzt
haben wir es hier auch in der rede aber
ist ihnen bewusst dass wir in der
sondersitzung die ministerin gefragt
haben ob sie sich gedanken gemacht hat
wie man das effizient verteilt und sie
uns gesagt hat sie geht davon aus das
funktioniert im moment die länder nähmen
das freiwillig ab ist ihnen bewusst dass
wir im ausschuss in der sondersitzung
gefragt haben ob sie sich gedanken
gemacht hat bzw war dann nur noch der
staat katar die ministerin war dann
schon weg über die kosten weil wir jetzt
schon wussten damals schon wussten dass
die kommunen fragen der bezahltes was
können wir anbieten und die antwort des
staatssekretärs war über so was müssen
wir uns jetzt noch keine gedanken machen
waren sie da anwesend und ist ihm
bewusst dass diese mehrere kernfrage im
zusammenhang der bewältigung der
flüchtlingskrise da keine antworten
kamen ist und das löst sich alles von
alleine
liebe frau kollegin da wir gemeinsam an
allen ausschusssitzungen des
innenausschusses in der vergangenheit
teilgenommen haben was zumindest diese
wahlperiode angeht ist der letzte teil
ihrer frage ob wir gemeinsam anwesend
waren ja frage sie aber auch umgekehrt
frage sie aber umgekehrt ob ihnen
bewusst ist dass es eine erheblichen
unterschied zwischen der
iss ich frage sie umgekehrt ob es ihnen
bewusst ist dass es einen erheblichen
unterschied dazu gibt wie die vorgänger
von frau nancy faeser als
innenministerin mit der frage von flucht
und migration umgegangen sind ich
benenne namentlich thomas de maizière
ich benenne auch horst seehofer den
letzten zwei jahren der pandemie im
übrigen als zuständiger minister für den
bevölkerungsschutz vollkommen auf
tauchstation war frau kollege wir haben
ein zwei lehren aus der ausfall wäre
2015 2016 gezogen und ich sage ihnen
ganz konkret erstens haben wir als
ampelkoalition auf eines geachtet dass
wir die obleute und sprecher aller
fraktionen des innenausschusses in
regelmäßige lage briefings einbezogen
das gab es bei cdu/csu nicht der erste
der zweite punkt ist im rahmen dieser
gespräche ist regelmäßig fragen sie
ihren sprecher ist in mindestens drei
besprechungen gemeinsam durchgeführt vor
im rahmen dieser besprechung ist
dynamisch über die lage informiert
worden dass in den ersten wochen sich
das geschehen der migration
unterschiedlich verhalten hat zu dem
zweiten teil der mit witz und wir
redeten zu anfang über mehrere tausend
und eine große welle der freiwilligkeit
wo länder angeboten haben nachdem
pletzing verfahren wir bieten plätze an
und wir wollen keine verteilung haben
als wir feststellten dass bestimmte hot
spots entstanden sind wie berlin wie
hamburg und die länder auch deutlich auf
den bund zu gegangen sind haben wir
gesagt wir müssen zu einer festen
verteilung übergehen das ist im rahmen
dieser besprechung auch angesprochen und
thematisiert wird wir sind das ist ein
zitat noch nicht an dem punkt der festen
zu weiß und wir werden an diesen punkt
kommt dritter und letzter punkt kollegin
ist ihnen ist herr kollege uns zu ich
sage ihnen ist ihnen bewusst dass der
nun in rede stehende § 24 des
aufenthaltsgesetzes der novelliert
worden ist und auch entsprechend in das
deutsche recht eingefügt worden ist zu
zeiten der union in das aufenthaltsrecht
übernommen worden ist und die regelung
dort seit regierungswechsel nicht
verändert worden sind und die
kapazitäten der deutschen würden auch
nicht verändert wollen sind das heißt
sie tragen und kern dafür verantwortung
dass das recht existiert und dass sie
dieses auch anwenden lassen müssen uns
einen unterschied gibt den wir hier auch
noch erwähnen müssen zur ostsee vor und
thomas de maizière nennt sich leser ist
die erste hin ministerin der es gelungen
ist in deutschland das alle europäischen
staaten an einem strang ziehen und nicht
der deutsche innenminister auf
tauchstation wenn angela merkel sich
gegen den rest der europäischen staaten
bestellten ursächlich schaffen das und
das ist ihre verantwortung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und das geht nur in diesem fall sonst
erwartet der massen sie schauen sich
nicht das verdeck und der geflüchteten
an ist in diesen bereichen wahl wollen
und kinder und gebrechliche und sie
diskutieren über registrierung die
versuchen uns auseinander zu treiben
anstellen zusammenstellen dieser
situation für unser land und diesen
kontinent fordert sie werden hier war
heute wichtig
und da die zeit weiter läuft machen wir
ein angebot an die union weil sie ja die
demokratische opposition sind wir können
das jetzt in jeder innenausschusssitzung
durchexerzieren sie haben 16 jahre lang
die verantwortung getragen sie haben es
doch nicht auf die kette bekommen sie
waren doch auf tauchstation und sie
versuchen jetzt das auseinander zu
treiben aber wir werden stärker sein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen denn es
ist eine europäische ausschreibung und
es muss uns bewusst sein und natürlich
mal die ganz rechte ecke des hauses
wären zwei reden jedesmal geflüchtete in
den mittelpunkt stellt und angebliche
trittbrettfahrer was nicht ein einziges
mal schafft putin der diesen
angriffskrieg führt und dass die rosa
ist verurteilt der verpasst etwas
und uns muss bewusst sein ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen jetzt ist die
stunde europas gekommen jetzt kommt es
darauf an dass wir gemeinsam diese
humanitäre katastrophe bewältigen und da
wären der haushaltsberatung sind und wir
wissen dass es einen tag vor dem angriff
gab und einen tag davor als der
regierungsentwurf eingebracht worden ist
müssen wir auch in aller offenheit sagen
frau lindholz ich habe es gehört aber
ich kann es ihnen auch noch mal erklärt
wir müssen anerkennen dass der
regierungsentwurf von ihnen zunächst
eingebracht worden ist und vor uns
verbessert worden ist und er wird noch
mal besser werden weil es wird einen
weiteren schnitt geben müssen sicherheit
im wandel braucht auch mehr
investitionen und die sind sie schuldig
geblieben es waren ihre innenministers
waren ihre finanzminister die personal
abgebaut haben mittel gekürzt haben und
immer über die schwarze null geredet
habe aber zu selten über sicherheit
liebe kollegen sie
sind verantwortlich dass der
bevölkerungsschutz in deutschland nicht
leistungsfähig war der wahltag war ihr
horst seehofer flop und nicht unsere und
das wird nicht noch mal passieren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ganz anders
weil jetzt korrigieren und sie in der
opposition sind und das haben die
wählerinnen und wähler an schienen aber
wir werden mehr an den zivilschutz
investieren müssen das sage ich ihnen zu
genauso wie die friedensdividende
verbraucht worden ist was die
streitkräfte angeht müssen wir mehr in
den bevölkerungsschutz mehr zivilschutz
und mehr an den cyber schutz und die
server security investieren und ich bin
mir sehr sicher dass die ampel koalition
genau diesen weg in diesen
haushaltsberatungen gehen wird liebe
kolleginnen kollegen und das sage ich
ihnen zu und wenn sie dann doch einen
konstruktiven beitrag indem sie zum
beispiel auf die länder an wirkungen ein
gemeinsames wir schaffen das draus
machen oder wenn wir wirklich an die
seite der länder rücken wollen dann
werden wir diese krise auch gemeinsam
bewältigen und ich möchte mich an die
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger in diesem
land wenn ich glaube nicht dass uns noch
bewusster wird wenn wir sagen heute ist
der tag des waffenstillstandes in der
ukraine und wir hoffen auf diesen tag
dass dieser krieg endet aber die
menschen die jetzt schon nach europa
geflohen sind dreieinhalb millionen
menschen stand heute und da kommen noch
millionen von binnenvertriebenen
wer glaubt denn wirklich in diesem hohen
haus das mit dem tag millionen von
geflüchtete zurückgehen die ukraine wird
einen marshall plan brauchen zum
wiederaufbau wir werden beide in schulen
und krankenhäuser alles zerstört
investieren müssen und die drei jahre
die der temporäre schutz jetzt umfasst
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sind erst
der anfang es wird uns fordern und das
was passiert ist es im zeitraffer das
was
2015/2016 war binnen vier wochen lassen
sie uns als demokratischen kräfte in
diesem haus zusammenarbeiten
lasst uns dafür sorgen dass diese
gemeinsame aufgabe europas und
deutschlands bewältigt wird es seine
bund und länder aufgabe aber die kosten
dürfen nicht und das ist ein gemachter
fehler 2015 2016 erneut an den kommunen
hängen bleiben sie tragen die
hauptklassen dank an die
ehrenamtlerinnen und ehrenamt wir stehen
an ihrer seite
der innenpolitische sprecher der spd
diese was den radlern hier auch mit
vielen angriffen gegen den ehemaligen
bundesinnenminister außen sehen das wird
stephan mayer der neue generalsekretär
der csu hier sicherlich kontern sprecher
verspotten ehrenamt es auch noch aber
zunächst an einem können die mannen von
wolfgang kubicki das ergebnis der wahl
der mitglieder des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums ist gemäss artikel 45 g
das wollen sie jetzt bekannt zu geben
und mich dabei gleichzeitig bei den
schriftführern die diese auszählung
die hinter sich gebracht haben war sehr
umfangreich dass sie das also gut
geleistete mitgliederzahl des deutschen
bundestags 736 abgegeben bestimmt garten
642 von den abgegebenen stimmen
entfielen auf die spd 529 jahre stimmen
68 nein-stimmen 29 enthaltungen 16
ungültige stimmen auf sebastian hartmann
spd 526 jahre stimmen 72 nein-stimmen 31
enthaltungen 13 ungültige stimmen auf
den kollegen dort stehen der spd
448 jahr stimmen 142 nein-stimmen 32
enthaltungen
und 20 ungültige stimmen und auf maria
dieser fälle als spd-fraktion 5 528 ja
stimmen 65 nein-stimmen 33 enthaltungen
und 16 ungültige stimmen den kollegen
alexander hoffmann erzählt von den
vielen 525 jahre stimmen 43 nein-stimmen
50 enthaltungen und 24 ungültige stimmen
roderich kiesewetter cdu csu fraktion
535 jahre stimmen 40 nein stimmen 48
enthaltungen und 19 ungültige stimmen
auf die kollegen christoph de vries
diego csu-fraktion 503 ja-stimmen
58 nein stimmen 56 enthaltungen und 25
ungültige stimmen auf die kollegin dr
irene mihalic 502 bündnis 90/die grünen
520 jahr stimmen einen sitz ich nein
stimmen 32 enthaltungen und 19 ungültige
stimmen und nick cowling tochter
konstantin von notz bündnis 90 die
grünen 5 111 jahre stimmen 78
nein-stimmen 35 enthaltungen und 18
ungültige stimmen auf den kollegen
konzerne cool fdp-fraktion
532 jahre stimmen 61 9 stimmen 35
enthaltungen ungültigen stimmen auf die
kollegen alexander graf lambsdorff fdp
fraktion 539 jahre stimmen 51
nein-stimmen 38 enthaltungen und 14
ungültige stimmen auf den kollegen
joachim wundrak ag fraktion 90 jahre
stimmen 435 nein-stimmen 30 enthaltungen
und 87 ungültige stimmen auf den
kollegen der anderen fraktionen die
linke
341 jahre stimmen 180 nein-stimmen 72
enthaltungen und 49 ungültige stimmen
damit haben folgende abgeordnete
nachbar 2 absatz 3a über die
parlamentarische kontrolle der tätigkeit
des bundes die erforderliche mehrheit
von 369 stimmen erreicht und sind damit
als mitglieder des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums gewählt
uli goltsch sebastian hartmann doktor
ralf stegner walliser völkers alexander
hoffmann roderich kiesewetter christoph
de vries tochter irene mihalic
tochterkonzern von notz konstante coole
und alexander graf lambsdorff
sie sind damit als mitglieder des
parlamentarischen gremiums gewählt die
abgeordneten joachim wundrak und dr
andré hahn haben die erforderliche
mehrheit nicht erreicht und sind damit
nicht gewählt damit ist das ergebnis
festgestellt und das ist ein
überraschendes ergebnis meine damen und
herren denn andré hahn war bislang
mitglied im parlamentarischen kontrolle
von den linken er hat die mehrheit die
wirklich nur knapp verpasst bei einem
betrag von der afg konnte man sicherlich
davon ausgehen und jetzt der von mission
angekündigt sekretär der csu sparen
oder ihrem gewissen und ihrem erinnerung
vor allem etwas auf die sprünge zu
helfen es war bundesinnenminister horst
seehofer der nach diesem schrecklichen
attentat am 19 februar 2020 in hanaus
sofort eine außerordentliche
innenministerkonferenz initiiert hat und
dann auf sein betreiben hin 1 89 punkte
übergang zur bekämpfung des
rechtsextremismus der bundesregierung
auf den weg gebracht hat es war horst
seehofer ja etwa vor einem jahr mit dem
bka-präsidenten ein zehn punkte papier
noch weit vor dem vor der schrecklichen
hochwasserkatastrophe in reihenhäusern
nordrhein westfalen auf den weg gebracht
hat um das bbk um damit den katastrophen
und bevölkerungsschutz in deutschland zu
verbessern und zu stärken
es war horst seehofer der mit einigen
anderen regierungen in der europäischen
union eine koalition der willigen
geschmiedet hat um insbesondere
schiffbrüchige personen in deutschland
und den anderen ländern aufzunehmen also
sie gehen viele in ihrem urteil dass die
letzte periode eine schlechte periode in
der politik war das gegenteil war der
fall in keiner legislaturperiode seit
bestehen der bundeswehr haben die
sicherheitsbehörden in deutschland so
viel zusätzliches personal bekommen wie
in der letzten legislaturperiode das war
eine erfolgreiche das war eine kluge
register urteil wurde für ist
sicherheitsbehörden und auch mir einfach
zu sagen dass ihre rhetorik herr kollege
hartmann in keiner weise der
krisenhaften situation rechnung trägt
wäre uns deutlich durch da ist aus
meiner sicht mehr seriosität und auch
mehr wehmut angemessen sehr verehrte
frau bundesministerin ich bin der
auffassung dass sie diese idee der
koalition der willigen naturhaus
richtigerweise übernommen haben und ich
weiß selber wie schwer das ist wenn man
auch die ratspräsidentschaft innehat und
der 27 eu ländern hier einen kompromiss
zu bekommen trotzdem möchte ich ihnen
schon noch wärmstens ans herz legen sich
weiterhin nicht nur in deutschland für
eine gerechte verteilung der
ukrainischen kriegsflüchtlinge
einzusetzen sondern auch auf
europäischer ebene gezeigt und ich
könnte sie auch dringend endlich die
defizite zu beseitigen die nach wie vor
im bereich der registrierung bestehen es
ist nach wie vor ein defizit das nicht
lückenlos alle ukrainische flüchtlinge
nach deutschland kommen und wohlgemerkt
willkommen sind wird auch registriert
werden auch hier ist der bund am zug sie
lassen bis dato die länder die kommunen
und vor allem die zehntausenden von
ehrenamtlichen jämmerlichen stich eine
härte damen und herren und auch einem
anderen wichtigen
gesellschaftspolitischen bereich ist
derzeit von der bundesinnenministerium
noch nicht allzu viel zu hören aber das
ist der sport bereich in den ersten 100
tagen sind sie nur mit einer bemerkung
aufgefallen nämlich dass sie erklärt
haben sie würden nicht zu den
olympischen spielen nach peking reisen
das war aus meiner sicht mit verlaub
eine fehlentscheidung weil es unsere
athletinnen und athleten verdient gehabt
hätten dass sie auch durch ein mitglied
der bundesregierung vor allem dürfte
sportministerin anerkennung finden für
ihre leistungen und das war aus meiner
sicht eindeutig sieht darüber hinaus
wenn ich mir ansehe was im
haushaltsentwurf jetzt aktuell steht
dann ist ein zentrales vorhaben ihrer
bundesregierung nämlich die schaffung
einer unabhängigen instanz zur
mittelvergabe im spitzensport überhaupt
nicht abgedeckt durch irgendeinen titel
ansatz kein einziger euro steht in
diesem haushalt zu dieser unabhängigen
instanz und ein anderes wichtiges thema
unsere über 90.000 sportvereine die
jetzt wirklich gedacht und gelitten
haben in den zwei jahren der
chorakademie brauchen mehr als nur warme
worte sie brauchen auch entsprechend
geld auch hier diesbezüglich steht kein
einziger euro im haushaltsentwurf des
sportlers was die verbesserung und den
neustart der arbeit unserer über 90.000
sportvereine angelangt
und wir unterstützen sie sorgen ganz
nachdrücklich auch bei der schaffung
eines
eines sportzentrums also vor allem eines
zentrums zum gegenstand hat das wir
sexualisierte gewalt im sport bekämpfen
dass wir athletinnen und athleten davor
schützen dass sie psychische oder
psychische psychischer oder physischer
gewalt ausgesetzt werden nur wenn ich
mir dann ansehen dass dazu gerade mal
ein haushaltsansatz von 300.000 euro
drin steht dann ist dies vollkommen
unzureichend untersagt nicht nur ich da
sagt auch der verein athleten in
deutschland ev also mein klares petitum
sehr geehrte frau bundesinnen und
sportministerin hier wirklich endlich
die hausaufgaben zu machen der sport ist
eine der wichtigsten gesellschaft wie
einer der wichtigsten gesellschaftlichen
bereiche in unserem land und die
bisherigen aussagen und vor allem die
bisherigen haushaltsansätze tragen in
keiner weise rechnung jetzt wissen die
kollegen
stephan mayer der ja die letzten vier
jahre parlamentarischer staatssekretär
beim bundesinnenminister war jetzt wie
gesagt neuer csu-generalsekretär und
sprecher für sport und ehrenamt und er
hat angemerkt dass gerade in diesem
bereich ehrenamt kein geld vorgesehen
[Applaus]
ist jetzt vieles polat
auf die ukraine und die damit verbundene
millionenfache vertreibung führen uns
vor augen wenn wir heute über den
schwerpunkt des haushalts des
ministeriums für inneres und heimat
sprechen dann sprechen wir vor allem
über menschen und
das wird schon gesagt über einen neuen
stil an der spitze des hauses in der
flüchtlingspolitik zu gestalten und
nicht zu spalten meine damen und herren
minister hayes kompass ist auf die
menschen ausgerichtet nicht auf zahlen
sie spricht von verantwortung begriffe
die sturm- oder lawinen kommen ihr in
zusammenhang mit geflüchteten nicht über
die lippen
meine damen und herren diese haltung ist
es die unsere koalition in der
flüchtlingsfrage auszeichnet und sie
unterscheidet sich die mal diametral von
ihnen von der union meine damen und
herren
mit dieser haltung hat frau feser in
brüssel dazu beigetragen dass wenige
tage nach beginn des angriffs auf die
ukraine erstmals seit über 20 jahren die
eu richtlinie zum vorübergehenden schutz
von mit vertriebenen aktiviert wurden
und wie sie vom ministerium feser es
treffend formuliert hat wie renten
hätten menschenleben unabhängig vom pass
nach jahrelangen streitigkeiten und
offene abschottung noch nie zeigte die
europäische union sich so geeint in der
flüchtlingspolitik die geschlossenheit
und solidarität mit der die eu staaten
sich jetzt bei der aufnahme geflüchtete
aus der ukraine präsentieren ist ein
wichtiges signal dies muss eine
blaupause für die künftige europäische
flüchtlingspolitik sein einer politik
die die menschen in den mittelpunkt
stellt
die antwort auf die größte flucht
bewegung in europa seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg muss sich aber auch maßgeblich
im einzelplan 06 der neuen ampel
koalition abbilden und vor allem frau
ministerin in den beratungen zum
ergänzungs haushalt sie haben es
angesprochen
wir werden den aktuellen
herausforderungen mit einer
integrationsoffensive begegnen wir
treten ein für gleiche rechte von anfang
an ohne wenn und aber und unabhängig vom
passt meine da bot
deshalb müssen jetzt auch die
gesetzlichen weichenstellung
gestellt werden ich hatte das in meiner
letzten rede schon gesagt und frau
ministerin die mittel für die
integrations und sprachkurse müssen wir
noch deutlich erhöhen
teilhabe findet auf vielen ebenen statt
das wurde heute auch schon gesagt ich
möchte hier insbesondere auch den
kommunen danken die in vorleistung
treten und all den freiwilligen die mit
großem einsatz die aufnahme der
geflüchteten ermöglichen insbesondere
auch dem ukrainischen migrantinnen
organisationen die anerkennung dieses
engagement darf sich nicht auf worte
beschränken sondern muss sich noch
stärker im haushalt widerspiegeln und
frau ministerin ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal deutschlands ist
unser system der migrations erst
beratungsstellen auch hier reicht es
nicht die arbeits die arbeit der
wohlfahrtsverbände zu logen man muss sie
auch angemessen militär ausstatten
schließlich gilt es die vielen menschen
nicht zu vergessen die ins asylverfahren
gehen deshalb muss jetzt die
flächendeckende behörden unabhängige
asylverfahrens beratung kommen liebe
kollegin von der spd was
selbstverständlich sich auch im haushalt
abbilden muss
meine damen und herren
frau ministerin am 17 april wird es ein
gipfeltreffen geben der
ministerpräsidentin mit dem
bundeskanzler dort wird sich entscheiden
ob die menschen und ihre bedarf im
mittelpunkt stehen oder ob diejenigen
sich durchsetzen die menschen in
geflüchtete erster und zweiter klasse
einteilen und die integration ausbremsen
wollen
zur teilhabe von anfang an gehört es
geflüchtete aus der ukraine über die
leistungen des sgb zu versorgen sie
müssen krankenversichert und in den
arbeitsmarkt integriert werden teilhabe
gelingt nicht durch das abstellen in
sonder system der asylbewerberleistungen
liebe kolleginnen und das wird die
zentrale frage sein auch bei der
kostenteilung zwischen bund ländern und
kommunen auf den kommenden flüchtlings
gipfel denn bleiben die menschen im
diskriminierenden sonder system tragen
vor allem die kommunen die finanziellen
lasten diese frage erneut über
pauschalen regeln zu wollen das ist ein
griff in die mottenkiste der cdu und csu
sie hören aufmerksam zu herr kollege sie
wissen was ich hier gerade sage unsere
aufgabe ist es nun dass dieser haushalt
sowie der ergänzungsbau zeit vom geist
unseres koalitionsvertrags getragen
werden wir wollen einen neuanfang in der
migrations und integrationspolitik
gestalten da einem modernen
einwanderungsland gerecht wird ich freue
mich auf die beratung frau ministerin
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
in folge die pole
[Applaus]
die story ist der kollege jürgen könig
immer
könig ist der sprecher für sport sport
gehört ja auch zum
bundesinnenministerium
und ihren könig hat allerdings eine sehr
knappe resident kollegen und vor allem
liebe sportler der sport haushalt wurde
in der 19 wahlperiode quasi verdoppelt
nun ist korrelationen noch nicht
zwingend eine kausalität aber in diesem
speziellen fall war entscheidend dass
die afg zum ersten mal im deutschen
bundestag vertreten war
die neue bundesregierung
hat den sport haushalt immerhin stabil
gehalten war jetzt 313 millionen euro
ohne krone helfen wie als ausgewiesene
sportsfreunde von der afg fordern aber
ein aufwuchs von auf 360 millionen euro
im haushaltsjahr 2022 und konstruktiv
wie wir sind haben wir die entsprechende
haushaltsanträge schon vorbereitet
langfristig fordern wir ein sportler von
einer milliarde euro also in etwa der
größenordnung wie die kultur für die hat
der bund nämlich auch keine originäre
zuständigkeit
wir können uns das als sportnation und
das höre ich immer wieder als reiches
land ganz locker leisten
es gibt allerdings auf warnsignale aus
dem wichtigen haushaltstitel zentrale
maßnahmen auf dem gebiet des sportes
wurden 33 von 191 millionen euro im
jahre 2020 nicht verbraucht was war der
grund für diese 17 prozent
minderverbrauch corona die verschiebung
von olympia in tokio vielleicht
vielleicht gibt es aber nach jahrzehnten
der vernachlässigung des sports gar
keine sportler trainer und strukturen
mehr die die erfreulichen erhöhung der
letzten vier jahre sinnvoll aufnehmen
können
wir von der alternative für deutschland
haben in der vergangenheit immer wieder
vorschläge gemacht um den
gesellschaftlichen stellenwert des
sports zu erhöhen wir haben uns mit
anträgen dafür eingesetzt dass es für
einen olympiasieg hunderttausend euro
gibt dass die trainer vergütung sicherer
und mit inflationsausgleich ausgestattet
wird und dass die fördergrenze für
sportgroßveranstaltungen aufgehoben wird
wir von alternative für deutschland
werden auch in zukunft für den sport
genauso weitermachen
sport frei und vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank könig ja
er hatte nur zwei minuten hat aber doch
viel gesagt wie ich finde da sieht man
mal dass auch zwei minuten recht lang
sein können und es geht weiter mit den
sportpolitischen sprechern jetzt der
nächste redner kommt von den liberalen
in der 47 philipp habe ich er ist eben
sportpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau sportministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ein bereich der
in vergangenen jahren besonders unter
den pandemie bedingten einschränkungen
gelitten hat ist der sport der sport mit
all seinen facetten von der
gesundheitsprävention über den
klassischen breitensport die gesamte
fitness branche bis hin zum
leistungssport es da unsere besondere
aufgabe und verantwortung den sport zu
schützen zu unterstützen und zu
entwickeln
beim schutz vor einschränkungen mit
debatten impulsen für die
gesellschaftliche bedeutung des sports
bis hin zum fundament erfolgreicher
sport politik und insbesondere für uns
als grund für besondere für erfolgreiche
spitzensport politik den finanzen der
spitzensport etat im einzelplan 6 und
hier sind wir um beim breitensport sind
wir auch in anderen bereichen kollege
meyer zum beispiel beim bau bereich von
vor zwei tagen ist ein solches fundament
vorliegend der vorliegende entwurf mit
einem deutlichen aufwuchs ist angesichts
der schwierigen haushaltslage ein
starkes signal
es ist eine gute stärkung des
spitzensports und deutschland braucht
wettbewerbsfähigen sport spitzensport
genauso wie uns athletin athleten beste
training zu wettkampfbedingungen
benötigen der entwurf beinhaltet
unterstützung aller beteiligten akteure
die an wertvollen beitrag leisten von
der verbandsförderung unmittelbare
athleten förderung athleten vertretung
durch athleten deutschlands kampf gegen
doping förderung der sportstätten für
hochleistungssport die förderung
nationaler in harten sparkurs
veranstaltungen bis hin zum wichtigen
und notwendigen aufwuchs bei at&s
erfolgreicher spitzensport hat viele
baustellen baustellen bausteine im
zentrum stehen dabei aber natürlich die
wichtigsten aller akteure die
athletinnen und athleten die mit größter
disziplin an lebensträume arbeiten und
dabei unsere besten botschafterinnen und
botschafter in der welt aber auch für
unsere jugend sind danke aber auch an
der stelle an alle beteiligten die